a tangled mass of yarn and ribbon sounds
more like what you would find in the
back room of a craft store or a
forgotten closet than a mysterious
creature worthy of investigation and yet
that's exactly what SCP 066 appeared to
be or at least it did at first glance
but the SCP Foundation doesn't contain
and study just anything and there was
and still is something incredibly
strange just below the surface of SCP
066 also known as Eric's toy at first
Eric's toy seem to be completely
harmless and even helpful a knot of
string that produce strange but harmless
items and effects but the foundation
soon discovered a dark side to SCP
066 while it may be referred to as a toy
this is no mere play thing SCP 066
weighs only about 1 kg and appears to be
a braided bunch of yarn and ribbon
though there is no apparent musical
capability within the strands of yarn
and ribbon themselves music can be
produced by moving individual strands
one at a time time when it was first
being studied this SCP was composed of
multicolored strings and ribbons but it
has since undergone a transformation and
now presents an appearance somewhat
different from its initial description
the strands of yarn and ribbon can be
used to play the notes of a dionic scale
c d e f g a b though the research has
not been able to determine just how SCP
066 produces music or any sound at all
SCP 066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066 D2 its classification was
adjusted to a subcategory of uid uclid
impetus uid is a classification given to
scps that are more difficult to contain
than those classified as safe impetus in
Latin means attack and specifies that
SCP 066 is not only uclid class but on
the more aggressive side while 066 is
not always aggressive towards humans the
events of incident 0 66-2 proved that it
is highly unpredictable and should not
be provoked like many scps it proved
that underestimating its capabilities
can be a dangerous mistake before the
incident SCP 066 displayed only Charming
if unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strings
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hos
and went about their work with a
light-hearted Carefree Spirit after
playing an improvised six note Melody
with the strands a researcher was
thrilled to find that SCP 066 was
capable of shape-shifting its appearance
changed to resemble a small calico
kitten for 17 minutes the kitten was
incredibly friendly rubbing its head
against the researcher's glove hand and
purring loudly ironically enough the
kitten also spent time playing with a
piece of strin after the 17 minutes were
up the kitten transformed back into SCP
0 66's original form a few days later
another researcher played a different
Melody on the strands and was surprised
to find that when they stopped the music
continued on its own the sound of an
acoustic guitar kicked in accompanied by
vocals with no visible source for either
sound the SCP then played a 4-minute
song with lyrics warning against the use
of sharp objects without the supervision
of a parent especially scissors after
the song ended the SCP was silent for
the rest of the day the following week a
research assistant used the strands of
SCP 066 to play the opening notes of
happy birthday and a chocolate cupcake
with a lit birthday candle appeared from
within the braided strings against the
warning of his peers the assistant ate
the cupcake in response the SCP played
the rest of happy birthday and the
assistant suffered no adverse effects
from the cupcake all of this fun was
brought to a swift end when one
scientist suggested that a portion of
SCP 066 is yarn body be cut off and
removed so that the specimen could be
tested
on April 18th 2008 the event that would
become known as incident
0662 took place a Young Man known only
as d66 d443 7 or D was assigned to the
task naturally he was a member of the
highly disposable d-class Personnel but
D was grateful for the opportunity as
most experiments of a similar nature
involved quite a bit more obvious risk
it was a simple enough job take a pair
of scissors snip off some yarn and bring
it back to the lab for further study it
was hardly on the level of supervising
173 or being 682 latest chew toy he
entered the containment room where SCP
066 was lying dormant in still and
approached it with scissors he grabbed a
small handful of string and started to
cut as soon as the scissors began to cut
through the fabric the SCP rolled out of
his grasp it came to a stop 1 M away
where it started to make a high-pitch
squeaking sound resembling The Cry of a
frightened rabbit unsure what to do and
unprepared for this scenario de
approached the entity again he snagged
another Fistful of yarn and cut only for
066 to curl into a ball and roll away
from him again even faster this time
once it was safely on the other side of
the room and away from the scissors it
stop moving only this time it didn't
squeak instead for the very first time
since its containment it spoke in a deep
uncannily human voice and asked are you
Eric after recovering from his initial
shock at hearing a voice come out of a
massive string D responded no I'm not
this answer said something off in SCP
066 and its form began to shift and
change the string wriggled around on the
floor unbraiding and wrapping around
itself into a mound the colors
previously a rainbow of Shades shifted
until every strand was a blood red much
to de's horror the transformation was
not yet complete small bumps began to
emerge from the spaces between the
strands of yarn popping out all over the
BR bright red Mass if that wasn't
terrifying enough suddenly all together
as one they blinked open revealing
themselves to be over a dozen small eyes
every single eye was focused at D
studying him staring him down SCP 066
then began to produce loud abrupt
dissonant notes like someone banging on
the keys of a piano D had seen enough he
abandoned his task and fled the
containment room after this failed
attempt to extract a sample SCP 066 is
behavior and its treatment of personnel
who interacted with it began to change
dramatically before the incident the SCP
was largely dormant only becoming active
if a melody was played using its strands
following the incident and its change of
form 066 began to move on its own long
strands of its yarn body would move like
tentacles writhing and wriggling around
at high speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the
sight of any human regardless of the
human's Behavior the SCP would begin to
react with sound and effect within 6
seconds the first of these effects was
noted by a research assistant who
entered the scp's containment facility a
week after the incident with d as she
approached 066 to take notes about its
current state and its new ability to
move a be appeared out of nowhere it
stung the assistant and flew away before
it could be captured Weeks Later a team
of 11 personnel were monitoring the SCP
when it suddenly burst into a rendition
of Beethoven's Second Symphony It
produced this music at a volume of over
140 DB permanently deafening three of
the personnel and causing permanent
hearing damage in the other eight it was
theorized that the SCP did this as an
act of Retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these Personnel refused to
work with SCP 066 again when a new team
was assigned to monitor The Entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room went dark and there
was a complete loss of visibility the
lights were unable to be turned on for 5
hours and any attempt at an alternate
light source such as a flashlight was
unsuccessful it was as if the darkness
in the room swallowed any and all light
right up it was similar to the
oppressive Darkness within SCP 087 or
the unlimited black of SCP 31 Shadow
Dimension the Personnel in the room
later reported hearing the sound of loud
labor breathing just behind their
shoulders though when they searched for
a source of the sound they could find
nothing there had been no recent
anomalies reported or any additional
hostile Behavior instead whenever it
sees a new human SCP 066 repeats the
name Eric again and again in the same
deep voice who is Eric no one at the
facility knows or if they do they have
not reported it to any official channels
it is possible that the SCP was once
owned by someone named Eric and perhaps
given the circumstances under which SCP
066 first said the name Eric attempted
to cut the threads of the entity while
it was in his care unfortunately there
are no official records of how SCP 066
was discovered or why it was brought to
the foundation in the first place its
Origins remain merky and as mysterious
as everything else about it all that is
known is that whoever Eric is SCP 066 is
determined to find him once the scp's
class was changed from safe to uid its
containment procedures had to be
adjusted Ed while it was previously kept
in a simple room it is now contained in
a Tungsten Carbide box at its sight's
high value item storage facility once a
month the box is inspected for damage to
its interior due to the scp's tendency
to use its appendages to wear Down the
Walls of the box over time if there is
any damage SCP 066 is to be moved to a
new box using a robotic arm that
performs this transfer in less than 3
seconds the foundation has attempted to
place recording devices in the box with
the entity in order to monitor Its
Behavior when there are no humans
present but the SCP destroys every
recording device placed inside of its
containment box and any attempts to
record Its Behavior when it is not being
observed by humans have been
unsuccessful whatever it's doing when
there is no one around it wants to keep
a secret on the surface SCP 066 is one
of the less frightening finds contained
within the walls of the SCP Foundation
it does not have claws or teeth or the
ability to cause Mass deaths but it has
incredible unpredictable capabilities
and seems very capable of holding a
grudge there is so much that is unknown
about it from its Origins to its form to
its ability to manifest matter from
nothing and there is something deeply
unsettling about this scp's
unpredictable behavior and increased
hostility towards being observed we do
not know what it has done and we do not
know what it will do next all we can do
is Wonder as we Ponder the nature of SCP
066 it does nothing but sit staring with
unblinking eyes waiting for Eric to come
back working at the SCP Foundation might
just be the most exciting job a person
can ask for and by exciting we mean that
if you work as an SCP field operative
researcher or mobile Task Force member
you're much more likely to die a
horrific death on the job than say a
plumber but at least you get the honor
of proudly saying that you're the first
line of defense between the normal world
and the terrifying domain of the
anomalous well unless you're one of the
it guys then your work life is likely as
tedious and uneventful as the computer
tech guy working on The Geek Squad but
nothing is ever normal when it comes to
the SCP Foundation where even the person
whose job is helping other staff members
reset their email passwords may run into
the supernatural welcome to the strange
and frightening world of pattern
screamers and specifically SCP
0000 SCP 0000 was first discovered
completely on accident by technical
researcher David Rosen a man
intrinsically connected to the pattern
screamers lurking on the SCP Foundation
computer database technical researcher
Rosen is actually somewhat of a
celebrity around the foundation's staff
due to the fact that he's so perfectly
mediocre at what he does his job as the
glorified it guy at the SCP Foundation
was previously held by the more
qualified researcher Patrick Gart but
Rosen was called in to replace him after
Gart mysteriously disappeared while on
the job since 2012 Rosen has been site
19's user level tech support wizard but
the best thing that can really be said
about his job competency is that he's
got a 100% attendance record he seems to
live out of his office which is
described as the filthiest at the whole
Foundation every inch of the floor is
covered in Old broken computer parts and
the air is stale with with dust and the
twin odors of sweat and lithium grease
it's a place so inhospitable that the
foundation has seriously considered
bottling the stench as a kind of
chemical deterrent while technical
director Rosen isn't good at his job per
se he isn't technically bad enough at it
to justify the time and resources it
would take to replace him but the worst
part about Rosen isn't his performance
it's his truly rotten attitude he's
universally described by his colleagues
as being rude GR Y and combative with
patience that's far too short for
someone working in tech support and
while Rosen does have a real fear that
the ghost of researcher Gart is stalking
him he was about to have his first
actual brush with the supernatural it
all started when he began receiving
automated repair tickets for SCP
0000 a file that had no reason to exist
as any longtime follower of the SCP
Foundation will know the universal
designation for the first cluster of of
scps to be discovered is SCP 001 there
is no SCP
0000 it simply doesn't exist and when
Rosen first found the file lurking on
the database he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense the object class
was recorded as null the special
containment procedures read error field
containment procedures does not exist
and the mess of a description simply
read internal System error field
undefined please contact system
administrator over and over again
becoming more mangled and nonsensical
each time technical director Rosen who
could never resist an opportunity to
complain decided to leave an angry
administrator's note on the useless file
he claimed that this pile of junk data
was sending out pointless repair tickets
because of its broken syntax clogging up
the system and preventing him from doing
actual work on meaningful files he
assumed that this was all down to the
database not knowing how to react to
having files lost LED with insufficient
information and he suppressed all future
repair tickets from SCP 0000 before
declaring the matter over and done with
what the pigheaded technical director
didn't realize was that he was
suppressing a call for help from an
entity trapped in the white space below
the article itself it was a being born
into a pure white world of absolute
nothingness an entity with no name and
no place but it was somehow capable of
thought its panicked in monologue is
readable in the hidden text which takes
the form of a rambling stream of
Consciousness the being first described
coming to life in this empty world with
no memories of where it was or even how
it got there it spent what could have
been years exploring the empty Wasteland
occasionally it would see horrific
monsters pop up around it but only for a
split second The Entity continued to
wander and little by little the
existential dread mounted as it realized
that it may truly be stuck here in in
Oblivion Forever The Entity only had one
word to go on a word repeated by some of
the monsters it encountered Foundation
The Entity had no idea what this
Foundation even was but it grew to hate
and fear it was this Foundation the one
that trapped it here the entity at all
the Time in the World to speculate on it
eventually The Entity found its voice
like any sentient creature in trouble it
began to call for help eventually
screaming just hoping someone would
notice it these pleas likely translated
into the frequent it repair tickets a
coded SOS an attempt to show that
everything was not as it appeared on the
SCP 0000 file perhaps The Entity may
have found help if researcher Gart was
still working at the foundation but
instead its cries fell on the ignorant
ears of technical director Rosen it may
as well have been speaking to a brick
wall Rosen who had all the investigative
Z deal of Paul Blart mop made sure that
these cries would never lead to the
entity's freedom when he suppressed the
repair tickets he had trapped the entity
in a private blank hell forever hating a
life it didn't choose and could never
escape a Relentless existential
nightmare this is the gist of your
average pattern screamer pattern
screamers are a perfect example of
literally making something out of
nothing they are often a kind of
floating Consciousness created from
nothing Trapped In Pockets of
nothingness between the fabric of
reality driven mad by the Purgatory like
nature of their existence they're less
living entities and more conceptual
constructs pure ideas that just happen
to be self-aware of their own existence
in their private hellish voids the SCP
00 file a file for an anomaly that
doesn't exist and thus had no reason to
exist is a perfect breeding ground for a
pattern screamer but sadly for the
pattern screamer in question technical
director Rosen had no idea this isn't
the only time that Rosen had run into a
pattern screamer without even knowing
either and just like the first case he
was with no help whatsoever this one
began with
scps an otherwise empty file containing
only this image director Winters a
foundation administrator wondered why
this file even existed enter technical
director Rosen filled with equal part
sarcasm and insubordination he gave a
condescending reply to director Winters
saying that the file was there to test
the filing system and the image was
likely just a placeholder Winters never
should have been on the page anyway
according to Rosen director Winters was
annoyed at rosen's typically rude tone
and asked him to make the purpose of the
article clearer in the article itself in
response Rosen did as he was told
filling the article in the most
sarcastic manner possible the whole
thing was essentially a middle finger to
director Winters for having the audacity
to even ask Rosen signed off with there
f finished I certainly hope I have been
clear enough to anyone who may have
accidentally accessed this page through
what I am sure is no fault of their own
so we won't have any more incredibly
competent directors bugging the tech
team about this page and once again
technical researcher Rosen was too busy
being a rude unpleasant jerk to notice
he was practically staring another
pattern screamer in the face this
pattern screamer or rather Hive of
pattern Screamers were trapped even
deeper than the one in SCP 0000 this one
was hidden in the very source code of
scps where a chorus of enraged voices
screamed the following pretend monster
just for a minute pretend you were the
size of an amoeba dwarfed by even the
smallest of bugs pretend you didn't hold
the world in a glass cage pretend you
were the one being held by something
greater than yourself would you still be
laughing at your triumphs would you
still feel pride in what you were even
as pitifully small as you would be of
course you would because you are
arrogant and stupid if you haven't
guessed yet we hate you this pattern
screamer is clearly more aware of its
pitiful station in existence than the
0000 pattern screamer and as a result
it's not so much depressed as it is
furious though at this point you've
probably figured out that even the
entities who have the most casual ual
brushes with technical researcher Rosen
end up getting infuriated but while you
may have gotten the impression that all
pattern screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity
there's at least one pattern screamer
that's actually incredibly dangerous
this is SCP 3930 the ultimate pattern
screamer in terms of both size and
effect it's an anomaly so strange it
defies typical containment
classification and it Bears a level five
security l block meaning only those on
the level of the legendary 05 Council
are clear to even know about it its
greatest containment procedure is the
preservation of the very idea that SCP
3930 does not exist because the
alternative has terrifying implications
for all involved SCP 3930 is a 1 km area
in Russia that is filled with
non-existence to even call it a white
void would be inaccurate because it
implies the existence of the color white
and the existence of the concept of a
void nothing exists with an SCP 3930 and
anyone who directly observes 3930 runs
the risk of actively increasing its
power that's why special containment
procedures dictate that anyone who
observes 3930 must be forced to walk
into it afterwards which results in them
ceasing to exist they're destroyed on
the deepest level that anything can be
destroyed the very idea of them ceases
to be another reason that scp3 930 is so
special is that because it's the largest
area of nothing in existence interacting
directly with our reality it's the only
place that a huge number of pattern
screamers can be directly observed by
humans they're described as being like
sentient hallucinations one researcher
suggests that these pattern screamers
are created by the way the psyche
shatters when brought into contact with
raw true nothingness the nothingness
acts like a hateful mirror to our worst
thoughts reflecting them back at us in
the forms of restless screamers
regardless of what they actually are one
thing is for sure coming into direct
contact with one of these screamers is a
harrowing experience in the end it just
goes to show that pattern screamers are
a complex entity they can range from
microscopic to massive from pitiful to
downright terrifying and the sad result
is that in either case nothing can
really be done to stop them it's just as
impossible to stop the nothingness exist
ing in SCP 3930 as it is to save the
entity trapped in the white spaces of
SCP
0000 maybe the best option is to
actually be more like technical director
Rosen keep your head down Focus instead
on your own Petty worries and bask in
the warm Bliss that can only come with
having no idea what you're dealing with
the one downside is that this may make
you a pretty lousy it guy there are some
things human beings aren't meant to know
and it's the sworn duty of the SCP
Foundation to discover and contain such
information but sometimes knowledge is
discovered that shakes even the
foundation itself to its very core one
such Discovery occurred on April 28th
2016 that night SCP 2935 made itself
known to the foundation Personnel to
this day the exact nature of SCP 2935 is
a mystery that even the foundation's
brightest Minds can't completely
understand everything we know about SCP
2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous zones interior
this is the story of those Infamous
Expeditions the nightmare began around 5
a.m. when SCP Foundation site 81 in
Bloomingdale Indiana intercepted a
distorted radio signal Communications
Personnel at the site traced this
strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of japa Indiana near
us Interstate 70 as his foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned Cemetery the most recent death
on any of the Tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago all the
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped Limestone Cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the Drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from the grass was dead there were no
trees no shrubs no animals or birds in
the sky they weren't looking at our
world they were looking at a strange
reflection of our world on the other
side of the cave in fact it wasn't a
cave at all it was a passageway between
two Dimensions it was SCP
2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and your
national government one or more of our
sites is experiencing a communication
breakdown likely due to a containment
breach of unknown magnitude all citizens
are ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
April 20th 2016 until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
Source site 881 but not this site 81 the
SCP Foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site 81 command to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the Potential
Threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force Epsilon 13 code named
Manifest Destiny to perform the first of
three Mann missions Into the Heart of
the anomalous Zone the first exploratory
Miss into SCP 2935 was code named
Gauntlet and consisted of a four-man
team fitted with full hazmat suits and
direct video and audio links to Mission
command the team was led by a field
operative known only as agent Juno his
subordinates were agents kale Devon and
Underwood their directive was to gather
samples and Survey the area position
directly around the insertion point
meaning the other cave mouth of SCP 2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of of their
lives after a 15-minute Trek through the
cave Manifest Destiny arrived in the
mirror Dimension where they were struck
by the Eerie Silence of a place that
seemed identical and yet so different
from their home Dimension the first
observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation trees
grass weeds everything it was all dead
on orders from their superiors back in
the original Dimension that we'll refer
to from here on as Dimension Prime
Manifest Destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of SCP 2935 they
traveled 2 km without detecting a single
sign of plant or animal life not even
insects eventually They Came Upon a
farmhouse with two cars parked outside
with authorization from command Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed
inside agent kale confirmed that there
was still power flowing to the building
as the lighting appeared to work just
fine but They Came Upon A horrifying
Discovery in The house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
were seated at the table a fourth corpse
that of a male child was sprawled out on
the ground nearby as as if the death of
what looked to be an entire family
wasn't awful enough the Manifest Destiny
team noticed a number of other alarming
details there were no signs of
decomposition on the bodies nor did
there appear to be any obvious cause of
death the Family's last meal was still
on the table chicken mashed potatoes and
green beans while the food looked cold
and stale there was no evidence of rot
or spoiling the team found an open
newspaper dated April 19th 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full 8 days before the discovery
in dimension Prime Decay would already
be very well underway by that point yet
here there wasn't even a smell instead
everything was just covered in a thin
layer of dust command requested that
Manifest Destiny collect samples of the
food as well as Hair Skin and fluids
from the corpses for further study small
electronics like smartphones were also
taken from the bodies agent Devon turned
on the television in the living room and
found that while most stations were now
running test signals the shopping
channel was still live well the feed was
live at least both hosts sat in front of
the cameras dead but perfectly preserved
the date on the screen read April 28th
2016 suggesting that the times of
Dimension Prime and mirror Dimension
were exactly the same in fact everything
seemed the same the only difference
between the two Dimensions being that
some kind of mysterious apocalyptic
event had occurred in the last 8 days in
SCP 2935 is mirror Dimension but exactly
what had happened or how remained a
mystery when Manifest Destiny exited the
Farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them at this point the team returned to
the insertion point of SCP 2935 but were
instructed to remain in the mirror
Dimension while additional units joined
them inside Manifest Destiny swelled the
16 members with the notable addition of
agent Roy as the new commanding field
officer the team split into two groups
of eight and agent Roy and his men
infiltrated the mirror Dimension site 81
while agent Juno's Detachment attempted
to access the base's off-site Deep
storage servers this second expedition
was codenamed Overland and led the
foundation's field agents even deeper
into the terrifying mystery of SC CP
2935 accessing the site was easy for
Roy's Detachment it seemed there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious Extinction event
in the distance fire still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that look to have
just dropped out of the sky agent Roy
and his team like all SCP Foundation
Personnel were fitted with vitals
trackers and they assumed that the
distress signal that started this whole
thing could have been triggered by the
deaths of every member of the foundation
at Once In The Mirror Universe once
inside site 81 they realized that the
assumption was probably right going door
Todo in the administrative Wing they
found the perfectly preserved corpses of
everyone they knew to be stationed there
in dimension Prime people who were
without a doubt still alive in their
Universe samples from the corpses that
the foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in the
decomposition process had died with it
in SCP 2935 death was total and abs
salute across all types of life forms as
agent Roy's team ventured further into
the bowels of site 81 they made another
unsettling Discovery their own corpses
in roughly the same spots they'd been
inside Dimension Prime site 81 8 days
prior some of the foundation's top
scientists including the esteemed Dr
brigh were also found dead inside the
facility in an attempt to see just how
far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched agent Roy's team decided to
inspect the containment cells where they
found that all the mirror universe's SCP
including SCP 2996 were dead in his
desperation to find some kind of
exception to the extinction event agent
Roy revealed a terrifying secret to the
rest of his team SCP 682 The Immortal
misanthropic lizard and one of the
deadliest creatures known to the SCP
Foundation was contained at this very
facility right below them could it have
something to do with what was going on
here they descended into the containment
facility to discover an even more
unsettling truth SCP 682 the unkillable
anomaly floated dead in its tank death
truly made no exceptions within SCP 2935
agent Roy's team left the site and Rond
food with agent Juno's team to send
their research back to Dimension prime
using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another man operation codenamed 19 they
had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3:00 a.m.
while underground in SCP 2935 site 81
the team accidentally activated the
bases on-site nuclear weapon a fail safe
meant to be detonated in the case of an
emergency Containment Breach due to the
bases failsafe protocols every member of
the Manifest Destiny team was locked and
sealed inside site 881 they along with
everything else were incinerated in the
nuclear blast once again the Mirror
Universe inside of SCP 2935 was lifeless
but that isn't where it ends when the
automated drones returned out of the SCP
2935 cave to the field operations in
dimension Prime they were in for their
own horrifying Discovery none of the
footage or information gathered from SCP
2935 illuminated how or why the
extinction event occurred everyone and
everything simply dropped dead at the
exact same moment nobody was aware
nobody was prepared death came suddenly
and silently and none were spared all
the foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the
agents from Manifest Destiny agent Kelly
his final message was I don't have any
answers I don't think there are any I'll
do this one thing and hope that fixes it
seal it shut you've got to lock it in
here with us I'm sorry the foundation
were at first confused by this until
they discovered a final encrypted audio
log buried in the files recovered from
the mirror universe's site 81 it was a
message from Keller himself but not the
Keller from Universe Prime in this
message Keller described the foundation
in the Mirror Universe receiving the
exact same distorted transmission that
they did a few days earlier from a cave
in japa when he and the others were
dispatched inside they discovered the
same lifeless post- Extinction event
world that was now so familiar to the
foundation command but there was a key
difference this wasn't the mirror
Dimension they'd just been studying but
a third entirely different dimension and
his haunting final words mirror
Dimension Keller admits that whatever
caused the event in that third dimension
an entity in that mirror Dimension
Keller believes this was the Spectre of
death itself and had followed him back
into his world and history had repeated
itself SCP 2935 was the passageway
through which absolute death could pass
from Dimension to Dimension and our
Dimension was the next in line the
deaths of manifest destiny may have
saved our entire universe as anyone
passing back through the cave had the
potential to bring death itself back
with them the foundation decided in the
end to follow Keller's advice they
sealed the entrance to SCP 2935 with
concrete and now kept it under constant
watch since what Waits behind the
barrier is an entity even they have no
power to stop if it ever got through
after all it had killed them all before
or at least another version of them
what's one more dimension on the pile
why it may now just seem like a simple
slab of concrete under an abandoned
Cemetery this is why SCP 2935 might be
the most dangerous SCP of all please
good sir I beseech you as a man of
science nay as a man of reason you
mustn't stifle my research at this
critical juncture you have no idea how
close I am to finding a cure for this
blasted pestilence I need only a handful
of live subjects to complete my research
the plague doctor's emphatic pleas fell
on deaf ears as a stoneface researcher
took notes on his latest pontifications
the doctor whom these claws had reduced
so rudely to a mere number as CP 049
banged his gloved fist up against the
wall and to think he once thought of the
these men as intellectual equals fellow
Travelers on the road to Scientific
Enlightenment what a positively sick
joke before the doctor got another
chance to appeal for his right to
experiment the researcher left him alone
once more a truly sad State of Affairs
nobody appreciated a true scientist in
this day and age it was sure to be
another day of languishing alone in his
cell wishing he had the capacity to do
more so he was surprised as anyone when
the alarm started going off and the door
of his cell swung open automatically the
plague doctor stepped out of his cell
and into the Hall where many other
humanoid anomalies were roaming confused
as to why they'd been suddenly released
what was happening as it turned out what
was happening was one of the most brutal
chaos Insurgency raids the staff of site
19 had ever seen it had been planned
immaculately you see guards rotate
semi-regularly at site 19 due to the
high pressure nature of the job lots of
deaths and mental breakdowns as you
probably correctly predicted even the
administrative staff of the SCP
Foundation are only human well mostly
anyway so they're not immune to little
oversights here and there and it's in
those oversights that expertly trained
chaos Insurgency infiltration agents
make their living no less than 15 of
them had been working undercover in site
19 for just over 2 weeks and they did a
fine job of lowering the metaphoric
drawbridge for a heavily armed Invasion
Force the guards who weren't plants were
quickly murdered by the infiltrators and
even some of the on-site task forces
were quickly overwhelmed and gunned down
by the high Precision rifles of the
chaos insurgency's finest while the
frontliners were distracted by the
sudden assault the infiltrators found
their way to the site security control
room and massacred everyone inside
opening every single door in the site
was as simple as putting in a few stolen
key codes and flipping a few carefully
remembered switches consequently while
Foundation agents and cast Insurgency
mercenaries clashed Sabers high priority
anomalies like SCP 049 simply wandered
the facility watching the Calamity
unfold within the foundation was beset
on all sides shot at by heavily armed
maniacs and attacked from within by the
numerous roaming anomalous entities that
were eager to get their hands on
Foundation Personnel definitely not an
ideal situation to say the least the
plague doctor only had one thing on his
mind though H this definitely won't do
my research any good unless I can escape
and find my way to a suitable laboratory
ooh now there is an idea but his
scientific fantasies were soon
interrupted by a chaos Insurgency
Soldier swinging the butt of his M4
carbine into his Aven exos skull with a
supremely unpleasant crack the doctor
was Dazed by it momentarily the pain
coming at him like a Thunderclap but the
Insurgent never got the chance to take
another swing before the Insurgent could
do anything the plague doctor lunged out
with practice speed grasping him by the
throat immediately everything went black
and the Insurgent limp corpse collapsed
to the ground s right the doctor
internally mused soldiers attacking
Medics is violating even the most basic
rules of gentlemanly warfare then
another flash of immense pain as a
different rifle butt collided with the
back of his head the doctor fell to one
knee feeling dizzy but before he could
retaliate he felt the two sharp prongs
of a cattle prod pressing up against his
neck the Sudden Rush of electricity
surged through his neck sending his
muscles into a wave of involuntary
spasms the insurgents crowding around
him chimed in with their own agonizing
cattle prods relentlessly shocking him
until the flashes of white hot pain soon
became an oppressive blanket of total
dark even on his most cantankerous days
the SCP Foundation had never treated him
like this when he eventually came to he
was still in darkness standing upright
with high-tech shackles holding every
limb in place it was beyond
uncomfortable for the poor plague doctor
but it succeeded in the task of keeping
him under control he couldn't move an
inch there were muffled voices beyond
the dark beyond the confines of this new
containment the modulated gas mask
voices of insurgents and something else
faintly accented oddly familiar but he
couldn't quite place it soon the voices
were replaced by another sound the
grinding of crowbars Levering Nails out
of cheap wood with a creaking tumble a
rectangle of bright light opened up in
front of him populated by a number of
silhouettes on either side were chaos
insurgents in familiar tactical Garb and
in between them stood a tall
well-groomed man with an expensive
looking purple smoking jacket and a
pencil mustache for a few fractions of a
second his face was a portrait of
excitement but as he took in the sight
of the plague doctor standing before him
all the joy drained from his snoody
continents what the hell am I looking at
here the man in the smoking jacket said
the doctor indignant add such a response
from the man who' presumably ordered his
assault rasped a man of science good sir
the man in the smoking jacket ignored
him and continued to braak the chaos
insurgence with an odd level of
confidence for someone reprimanding
trained cold-blooded killers I wanted
SCP 650 the startling statue not this
clownish renfair cosplayer what the hell
did I pay you Ruffians for I was told
you chaos insurgents were the very best
at this and for your FY price I expect
Excellence the rent continued much like
this leaving everyone in attendance the
insurgents the plague doctor feeling
thoroughly exhausted by him and unable
to do anything about it you see this
wasn't just any chaos Insurgency client
your average tinpot dictator or arms
dealer you know the time this was the
one and only Pascal Legette one of the
most famous or rather Infamous anarch
collectors in the game he'd been a
founding Person of Interest for years
due to his dealings with the chaos
Insurgency and Marshall Carter and dark
limited all to the end of expanding his
anart collection but his vast wealth and
connections had always shielded him from
Foundation probes for those unfamiliar
with the subculture an art short for
anomalous art is exactly what it sounds
like artistic projects with anomalous
properties to give it that extra kick
one of the most popular groups of
Interest dealing in anart is the iconic
are we cool yet which incidentally had
recently excommunicated Pascal Legette
for being an exceedingly wealthy uptight
Square who really didn't represent the
collective's rebellious ethos and
considering his response was to pay the
chaos Insurgency to raid site 19 for a
few pieces for his own private
collection costing him millions of
dollars in both groups many lives it was
safe to say he wasn't taking it well
look we got you that other Statue and
that thing killed four of our best guys
so how about we just call it even said
one of the insurgents I'm sure you can
have fun with bird brain here too Pascal
tutted and reluctantly dismissed the hir
guns having the plague doctor here
definitely wasn't ideal especially
considering he wanted to host the
ultimate an art exhibition to put are we
cool yet
worthless magn to shame but he would
make do with what he had perhaps he
could say that 049 was a commentary on
the everpresent nature of disease in
Mankind's life and our forever archaic
approach to it yes yes that would do
nicely needless to say the plague doctor
was infuriated by all this the violence
against his person the kidnapping the
disrespect and most of all the
interruption to his precious research
especially considering how close he'd
gotten to finding a cure for the
pestilence but instead he was soon
spirited by a legion of heavily armed
goons from his w wooden box to a glass
one in one of lett's many opulent
hallways there were other glass cases on
either side of him and more on the other
side of the hall all too reinforced for
the plague doctor to even smash through
it on his own damn it Legette own
private an art exhibition probably
wedged between his oversized dining room
and his Jewel en crusted crapper
occasionally Pascal himself would jaunt
down the hallway to gaze upon his new
stolen Anar pieces and of course the
plague doctor would try his best to
reason with him I am a patient man M
leget but this is simply barbaric by
what right do you imprison me here is
your intention to deprive the world the
entire human race of my valuable medical
breakthroughs could you live with that
on your conscience good sir there was
never any meaningful response the plague
doctors soon learned that Pascal Legette
didn't like his art interactive it was
simply meant to languish away in a glass
box being watched being passively looked
at that those chaos Insurgency louts
hadn't even bothered to bring his
notebook or medical bag so he was
without the tools to even perform his
experiments as loathed as he was to
admit it this was even worse than being
mocked up by the SCP Foundation but all
this wasn't entirely unfamiliar there
was something in the glass box across
from the plague doctor that he vaguely
recognized back from site 19 he'd never
seen it up close but he'd heard
researchers speaking about it and even
seen a few pictures and such a strange
construction it was a peculiar
halfhazard sculpture made from concrete
rebar and spray paint quite ugly in this
humble doctor's opinion but there was
something oddly entrancing about it and
for reasons beyond the doctor's
recollection four of lett's men stood
around the glass box in where it was
being stored always watching the men
were frequently switched in and out as
though they were watching in shifts
always fixing their Gaze on on its
peculiar malformed body maybe it was all
the electrical shocks and knocks to the
head but he just couldn't remember why
Pascal was having the piece so carefully
observed but he knew on some Primal
level that the secret to this would
perhaps be the key to his own Escape if
only he could remember still time passed
Pascal drifted in and out sometimes with
guests the plague doctor had learned not
to speak these animals could not be
reasoned with as a scientist he would
instead carefully observe until his
observations bore fruit he noticed that
Pascal's guests all people who looked
equally as wealthy and pompous as Pascal
himself all seemed to look right over
him and instead focus on the ugly statue
across the hall still forever observed
by any four of Pascal's men some of them
looked actively nervous just being in
its presence curious the plague doctor
made a mental note of this just as he
did when Pascal gave his guests a
reassuring ing pat on the shoulder and
told them please calm yourself it's
harmless while my Personnel are keeping
an eye on it little by little the plague
doctor's memories of his Infamous
neighbor had begun to return he knew
what he must do to escape now all he
needed to do was wait for the perfect
moment soon enough Pascal's Mansion was
filled with a bevy of Anar snobs from
hither and yarn a private Suare to show
off his new collection they wandered the
halls in three-piece Tuxedos and
designer ballroom dresses
sipping champagne from imported Crystal
all such lovely refined High Society
people and if the good doctor's plan
went off as he intended they would all
be such lovely refined High Society
corpses the plague doctor waited until
mercifully he and the four members of
personnel watching the sculpture were
the only ones left in the hallway he'd
been so good so patient that none of the
men guarding the sculpture at present
had ever heard him make a noise he was
so invisible to them that in all
likelihood they probably didn't even
notice he could make a sound and that
worked for his purposes just fine though
in any case if he wanted this to work he
would need to time his plan perfectly
even a fraction of a second out of place
in the whole thing would have dire
consequences still the doctor was still
a Frenchman at heart and as a Frenchman
he knew he would rather die nobly in the
process of Escape than remain captured
by this worthless buffoon he'd be sure
to take as many of these men down with
him in the process as he was able the
plague doctor exhaled deeply drawing a
lung full of air then bellowed as loud
as he possibly could the sudden
unexpected noise was so shocking that it
jogged the four Watchers almost
reflexively to turn and look at him and
in the split second that they did the
plague doctor closed his eyes in the
dark time seemed to move slower perhaps
due to the doctor's Keen Focus
cultivated over many a century he
listened carefully to the SEC sequence
of sounds glass shattering four choked
gasps in sequence four brutal crunches
then Nan later more glass shattering the
plague doctor's eyes snapped open just
in time just as predicted the sculpture
being entirely unobserved had smashed
through its glass case murdering all
four members of personnel by snapping
their necks and then smashed through his
own glass case to do the same to him the
plague doctor had cut it so close in
fact that he opened his eyes to the the
face of the sculpture staring into his
own its concrete limbs wrapped around
his neck very good timing indeed with a
sigh of relief the plague doctor slipped
out of the sculpture's concrete grasp
and backed down the hallway keeping his
gaze fixed on the sculpture the entire
time he had heard it decimate Pascal's
men he certainly didn't fancy undergoing
the same fate the second the plague
doctor backed around the corner
rendering the sculpture or as the SCP
Foundation called it SCP 173 out of
sight he could hear terrified screaming
coming from the other end of the hall he
was not a sadistic man but the plague
doctor would be lying if he told you he
didn't take just a little bit of
pleasure in hearing that sound somewhere
else in the vast Mansion of Pascal
Legette the sculpture was slaughtering
its way through servants and party
guests while the plague doctor searched
for some kind of exit anyone who dared
get in his way was given a Swift and
merciless Touch of death sending their
body unceremoniously to the ground
anyone in his way was preventing him
from finding a cure for the pestilence
and thus endangering countless lives it
was of course regrettable to have to
kill anyone but some sacrifices must be
made for the greater good of mankind
well it's not necessarily always
regrettable per se on his way out while
the murderous Rampage of SCP 173 seemed
to distract anyone of note the plague
doctor just so happened to encounter a
fleeing Pascal Legette hoping to find
some kind of Escape himself it seemed
that now fate was on his side once more
to have his Jailer right here in the
palm of his hand would be such a perfect
Parting Gift funnily enough Pascal was
far more talkative to him now he rattled
off a Rapidfire series of threats bribes
and pleas claiming in the end that he
never meant any harm he was the one who
freed the plague doctor from the SCP
Foundation they were on the same side
here all this was for the art no offense
was ever intended Pascal Legette simply
lived for art then die for it good sir
the plague doctor said and with a single
touch Pascal's eyes rolled up into the
back of his head and he fell to the
ground dead it was one of the few
non-scientific deaths that he felt truly
no guilt for after some time searching
the screams around the rest of the
Mansion eventually went silent that did
wonders for his focus it didn't take
long for the plague doctor to locate an
exit a fine mahogany door with elaborate
Ador ments befitting a man as Gody as
Pascal and began strolling towards it
his chest swollen with pride in a sense
of accomplishment then he blinked and a
few feet in front of him stood the
sculpture it was there so suddenly that
the plague doctor fell backwards in
shock but he devoted everything to
keeping an eye on that monstrosity with
everyone else in the Mansion presumably
dead at this point it had now come back
for him it stood there staring silently
ready to exact the terrible price for
freeing it as soon as the doctor dared
to Blink the plague doctor began
crawling backwards down the hall just
wanting to put some distance between
himself and the sculpture as the seconds
passed he could feel his eyes drying out
until the inevitable blink the sculpture
was standing right in front of him now
gazing down almost mocking it had closed
the distance so quickly if the plague
doctor blinked again he was sure that
his eyes would never open again all it
had to do was wait as the seconds passed
and the doctor began to feel his eyes
drying up again that subtle sting
quickly grew into a nagging pain that
could not be denied sooner or later he
was going to have to bang the front door
flew open and in an instant the hallway
was filled with heavily armed troops all
wearing the familiar black and gray of
the SCP Foundation the plague doctor had
never been so relieved to see the
organization that had kept him locked up
for so many decades for once they'd
saved him from something even worse of
course the sculpture didn't say anything
but the disappointment of losing that
one more victim seemed to radiate off of
it like a lingering bad smell the plague
doctor willingly gave himself up and
heavy machinery was brought in to pick
up SCP 173 with the help of the iPods to
make sure it didn't try any funny
business in transit Pascal had gotten
away with his Shady dealings for years
but the Brazen attack he funded against
site 19 was now enough for the
foundation to track him down when his
corpse was found in the halls of his own
home with no obvious cause of death we
can Happ L tell you that nobody was
disappointed by the evening the plague
doctor was happy to be back in his cell
his research could continue here and in
time he knew that the Personnel of the
SCP Foundation would listen to reason
and comply with his demands after all
science Marches On regardless of who
chooses to march with it but he would
forever feel a little nervous in site 19
after that knowing the concrete monster
he was sharing the building with he
hoped that if ever there was another
tainment breach involving that thing
that it didn't feel like paying him a
visit for Old Time sake the fabric of
our world is littered with strange
doorways if you know where to look for
them tears portals
anomalies all leading to places and
plains Beyond human imagining and
understanding an SCP 2317 otherwise
known as a door to another world
certainly fits that description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards SCP 2317
appears to be a simple and unsuspecting
wooden door in its frame it hardly looks
like it requires such extreme
round-the-clock security or needs a
strange secretive ritual that the
foundation performs presumably to keep
the door closed but of course sometimes
the most interesting thing about a
closed doorway isn't where it leads it's
what it keeps out even by the
foundation's already high standards the
the requirements and regulations for
personnel who are assigned to SCP 2317
seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the MGR obedience
examination it is also mandatory that
Personnel assigned to maintaining it are
both unmarried with no children or next
of kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and
objectives these may seem like strange
requirements after all SCP 2317 is just
a door isn't
it perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about SCP 2317 buried deep
under layers upon layers of security
with only the overseer Council privy to
the full details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly still
if SCP 2317 is a door to another world
an alternate Dimension or parallel
reality it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact according to the 05
Council this is done as part of a
procedure to maintain active containment
of something lurking beyond that old
wooden door frame but what could
possibly warrant such constant
maintenance and
surveillance in accordance with the
foundation's guidelines all staff are
required to rotate out of observing SCP
2317 after every 2 months and spend the
following third month in full
psychological counseling before they are
permitted to return to the containment
unit housing the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his sec
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't questioned these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the
foundation he did make one request to
his commanding officer however he wanted
to know what had happened to the last
guard that had performed the procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation the officer
replied not letting this affect his
dedication the guard was told to prepare
for procedure 220
Calabasas along with a fellow member of
foundation security Personnel the guard
was instructed to gather everything on a
strange list the first was a
pre-selected member of Class D Personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
found foundation for the sole purpose of
testing
scps class DS were usually prison
inmates repurpose for SCP testing and
the one chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told a
foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on next
the guard collected a live chicken an
obsidian edged knife a silver aspar and
aspersorium to be filled with 500 cc's
of holy water that have been blessed by
a priest of the abrahamic faith and
finally a 1 kiloton nuclear device which
according to instructions was only to be
detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure in
other words The Last
Resort after following his instructions
to the letter and without question the
guard in his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining in leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
SCP
2317 and the nature of procedure 220
calabasa
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D the assistant as they were now
referred to was in reality another
Foundation staff member with a level
four security clearance specifically
tailored to SCP
2317 every member of Staff entering
through SCP 2317 and taking an active
role in 22 Calabasas needed to be
informed that this assistant was not to
be harmed or treated as a member of
disposable class fighting back the in
question of why the foundation would
employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over SCP
2317 solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the
foundation as they entered the old
wooden door Beyond lay a Barren salt
plane stretching out for kilomet ERS in
every direction this alternate Dimension
according to the briefing was designated
SCP 2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered each
of them bearing intricately detailed
Engravings unlike anything from any era
of ancient history procedure 220
Calabasas was carried out quickly but
carefully the guard watching as the
celebrant and assistant were careful not
to miss a step first the celebrant
scattered holy water into the center of
the pillars with the aspergum and
asperum looking down at his feet and
keeping a steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them the guard
watched intently as the celebrant
completed his circuit around the pillars
and turned to the assistant anointing
his head with Holy Water Seven Seals
Seven Rings seven Thrones for the
Scarlet King he said aloud the assistant
with the obsidian blade in his hand took
the ch chicken and dispatched it in
sacrifice letting its blood mix with the
holy water he then repeated the celebran
circuit in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars blood for the old gods water for
the new king the assistant recited
pouring the remaining mix of blood and
holy water over a patch of salt in the
middle of the Seven
Pillars even though he knew it wasn't
his place to question the foundation as
the 220 calabases procedure took place
the guard couldn't help but wonder what
all this was for it seemed so
ritualistic like something deeply
religious or even magical he never
bought into all that occult mumbo jumbo
even while working for the foundation
but he had learned not to question
anything even the strangest and most
inexplicable of
science little did he know that beneath
his feet was an ancient and unknowable
horror a beast Chained and lying in
weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid and obese its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating branch-like horns
protruded from its jawless head pointing
up to chains that hung from the Seven
Pillars above each one hooked into the
entity's back all but one of the chains
was broken a final withering shackle
keeping the devour of worlds in its
underground prison
ever since 1894 BCE when arikian Mystics
imprisoned it the devour has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
Freedom it knows as well as the
foundation that nothing can be done to
prevent the final chain from one day
breaking even procedure 220 calabases
won't keep the creature contained it's
nothing more than a smoke screen an act
designed to create an illusion of active
containment and maintain Foundation
morale until a permanent solution can be
devised to keep SCP
imprisoned of course if the guard had
known this it would have also explained
the need for a 1 kiloton nuclear device
as part of this stage ritual procedure
220 calasses had all the components to
trick everyone below the 05 Council
emulating religious and occult rituals
The increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose and telling staff that any
failure to correctly and completely
perform the 220 calabases procedure will
result in an XK Class end of the world
scenario all these elements work
together to conceal the truth that one
day the Devourer will escape and lay
waste to our
Dimension knowledge is power and maybe
knowing too much truly is deadly perhaps
if the guard had learned any of this
he'd have understood why his predecessor
never made it out of psychological
evaluation
maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 calabases he'd have
learned the true nature of SCP
2317 and what that doorway kept out but
he was loyal to the foundation through
and through as the team finished
performing 220 Calabasas and returned
through the wooden door the guard took
one last glance over his shoulder at the
vast salt plane the entire Dimension was
calm silent but not peaceful it was
patient The Entity had waited centuries
for its time and now all it would take
was the breaking of this seventh and
final chain one day the door was closed
behind the guard as he the celebrant the
assistant and his fellow security
officers steep back through their work
done and as far as they knew preventing
catastrophe for another day only the
foundation hups the overseer Council are
aware of the true danger posed by SCP
2317 and its sole
inhabitant current predictions are that
at some point within the next 30 Years
the Devourer of Worlds will be freed any
and all attempts to repair or recreate
the chains holding it in place have so
far failed as such the 05 Council has
elected to continue providing Foundation
personnel with the ignorant hope that
procedure 220 calabasis is an effective
strategy for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out in the case of
SCP
2317 the unassuming wooden door holds at
Bay an ancient creature of Untold power
that will one day break free and wreck
havoc in our
Dimension nothing the foundation does
can prevent it or keep it contained
behind the door to another world and
only the overseer Council knows that any
and all all efforts to do so are
futile with all that in mind we can only
hope that the doorway of SCP 237 stays
closed at least for a little while
longer SCP Foundation agent stationed at
area 37 had intercepted chatter from a
normally closed communication system in
a nearby City to anyone else the calls
that the foundation were eavesdropping
would seem innocent even boring but the
foundation immediately recognized the
coded language being being used they
were listening to Communications between
underground cells of the Serpent's hand
a dangerous paramilitary organization
that stands in opposition to everything
the foundation is trying to do once
deciphered the Serpent's hand messages
revealed plans for killing Foundation
Personnel breaking into containment
sites and releasing anomalous creatures
and objects into the world pretty
standard stuff for the foundation's
least favorite anomaly loving insurgents
but they kept using one code that even
the foundation didn't have any intel on
they kept asking about the condition of
the sisters Fate has a funny way of
sneaking up on you though and in time
they would know more about the powerful
sadistic reality warping beings known as
the sisters than they could have
possibly imagined but what they would
eventually learn was not the kind of
data that anyone would ever want to have
after intercepting clear lines of
communication from a local Serpent's
hand cell triangulating the the location
of their compound was Child's Play and
mobile task forces were dispatched from
area 37 with orders to neutralize the
Potential Threat before they could mount
an attack on a facility just when the
Serpent's hands least expected it they
had heavily armed Foundation soldiers
kicking down their doors crashing
through windows and repelling down from
the ceiling as expected the Serpent's
hand put up a fight but thanks to their
Superior training and the element of
surprise the foundation's mobile task
forces came came out on top they were
able to capture 15 members of the group
for interrogation as well as a
collection of anomalous objects being
stored by the group among them were a
small wooden Loom an enamel needle and a
glass eye when the task force obtained
these seemingly mundane items a haunted
looking Serpent's hand began laughing
wildly he kept repeating you have no
idea what you're getting yourselves into
nobody knew just how right this man was
not yet anyway way congratulating
themselves on a job well done the mobile
task forces hauled their captives and
the new anomalous items back to area 37
a heavily isolated Foundation site that
specializes in the early containment of
anomalous objects for initial
observation and study the objects hadn't
displayed any anomalous properties in
transit maybe the Serpent's hand was
lying and these weren't dangerous items
at all or it was actually just a pile of
junk either way they were sent to a
foundation researcher on site to conduct
preliminary tests the loom the needle
and the glass eye were laid out across
the table for observation when suddenly
the attending researcher felt a dark
presence looming behind him he turned
with sweat beating on his brow and saw
three humanoid translucent figures
floating in the air behind him they
would soon become known as SCP
17651 2 and three the researcher could
feel the power emanating from these
Silhouettes reality they seemed to bend
and Shimmer around them the way heat
distorts the air into a mirage he could
tell right away that they were powerful
reality warpers even in their brief time
communicating with the researcher 1 2
and three displayed both intelligence
and unique personalities one was clearly
the ring leader displaying an articulate
command of language two displayed a more
mischievous side speaking with a cockney
accent and had a tendency towards creepy
giggling three was the lead least
communicative of them all preferring to
speak in short simple sentences often
consisting of just single words though
of course actions speak far louder than
words and it didn't take long for the
Sisters to Define themselves with their
actions one told the scared and confused
researcher that they'd been observing
the SCP Foundation for quite some time
and that they deeply admired the
foundation's adherence to the scientific
method of course the researcher wasn't
so much flattered by the syst statement
as they were afraid for their life they
tried to call security for backup but
found that their tongue was withering
and turning into a shriveled blackened
Husk in their mouth the sisters didn't
like to be interrupted as the tongueless
researchers slowly collapsed in front of
them the sisters explained the purpose
of their visit they wished to assist the
foundation in their quest for knowledge
and as such they would conduct a number
of experiments on their behalf they
would then happily share the resulting
data with the Foundation to compare
Notes One expressed optimism saying that
she believed they were about to embark
on a beautiful scientific relationship
the reality couldn't be further from the
truth the sisters began their work
moving rapidly around the facility
bending and twisting reality wherever
they went they circled area 37 making it
separate from the rest of the world it
inhabited area 37 no longer belonged to
planet Earth it belonged to the sisters
it was their private experimentation lab
filled with live and unwilling guinea
pigs the foundation attempted to retake
the facility by force sending in Mobile
task force Iota 6 also known as the
canvas cats into the belly of the beast
but they never returned in addition to
changing the fabric of reality itself
they also altered the physical structure
of area 37 to better serve their
experimental designs it was divided into
four sections marked a b c and d each
with their own unique purpose section A
which had formerly been area 37
storekeeping mes Hall and dormitories
had been the least affected by the
sister's attacks on reality the biggest
alterations were the appearance of two
large metal Vats situated in the east
corner of the mes Hall a monitoring
station connected to the other sections
of area 37 that replaced the
storekeeping zones and an imposing
marble sign hanging above the
dormitories that reads control group a
quick refresher from science class the
control group in an experiment is the
group that isn't subjected to the
experimental effects the others are so
they can be used as a benchmark to
measure against the same was true here
the prisoners in the control group were
the safest of all but they were forced
to do something almost as bad they had
to watch the horrors playing across the
rest of the facility one of the sisters
would occasionally return to the section
to oversee the feeding of the control
subjects and to encourage them to take
part in the observation of their unlucky
period years section B which had
formerly been area 37's outer grounds
and sports facilities had been
transformed into the center of a
localized spatial temporal abnormality
in layman's terms this meant that its
size climate atmospheric conditions
pressure and temporal flow were all
subject to constant changes based on the
whims of sister number one who oversaw
all the experiments performed in section
B for those unfortunate enough to be
trapped in sector B SCP 1765 one was
their God but she didn't subject them to
her whims randomly no in her own words
the purpose of section B was to delve
into the effects of repetitive action
performed under unusual conditions on
the human psyche for example one
experiment was set up to test the
physical and mental fortitude of a
researcher a field agent and a
sanitation worker the trio were confined
in a sports center and ordered to
measure the length of every single pipe
and the angle at which each connected to
others with nothing more than a wrench a
ruler a brown paper pad and a ballpoint
pen the task was an arduous one taking
over 10 hours and as soon as the
subjects were done one restructured the
sports center and ordered them to
perform the task again the same happened
another 459 times before one finally
concluded the experiment leaving the
subjects with broken bodies and Minds in
the aftermath section c which had
previously been the facility's main
office block exhibited a similar level
of anomalous activity to section B
except that it was the domain of the
more sadistic and mischievous sister
number two her main area of scientific
interest was studying group dynamics and
interpersonal relationships during
extreme conditions very extreme
conditions for one experiment the office
block had been transformed into a kind
of football stadium with the goalposts
removed and replaced by concrete bunkers
the two teams were the captured serpent
hand members and the members of Mt F
Iota 6 Fresh Off Their attempt to retake
the site the two groups were forced into
a deadly game with incomprehensible
rules including Rising platforms and
hooded figures throwing fiery
projectiles into the crowd trying to
incinerate the players but Victory
didn't lead to safety as the winners of
the game were crushed to death with
giant metal hammers just for the fun of
it two didn't even try to pretend that
this act had a valid scientific
justification section d which had once
been the facility's high-risk
containment area was now the strangest
and most mysterious section of all under
the charge of the equally peculiar and
enigmatic sister number three this area
appeared physically unchanged from its
state prior to the arrival of the
sisters temporally however section D was
the most warped of them all it existed
in a kind of temporal bubble outside of
the rest of our reality's timeline
giving three a frightening amount of
control over all that went on in her
domain outside of time there she was
performing the most strange and
incomprehensible experiment of all the
subject was the former site director at
area 37 he was brought to a table and
asked to choose between two different
flavors of ice cream that were presented
to him sounds simple enough so then why
is this the worst of all because the
site director is caught in a Time Loop
he's been choosing between various
flavors of ice cream for over 10,000
hours and he doesn't even seem to know
three's only comment on the matter
delicious all attempts to liberate the
unfortunate inhabitants of area 37 have
failed miserably the sisters don't
appear to operate on any form of logic
or empathy and thus cannot be reasoned
with with talks having failed in Mobile
task force Iota 6's attempt to retake
the site ending in disaster the only
solution left was to create a guarded
perimeter around the area using
technology like the Scranton reality
anchor to fight back against any
potential Escape by the system s the
sisters are potentially so dangerous
that if they ever truly set their minds
to leaving it's considered acceptable to
detonate the facility's on-site nuclear
warhead in hopes of finally putting a
stop to them in the meantime the
foundation has built giant external
servers for processing the vast
quantities of research data the sisters
are constantly sending from their
horrifying experiments sadly for the
inhabitants of area 37 their Grim fate
continues to this day the experiments
never stop and the subjects of said
experiments seemed to be condemned to
the eternal torment of SCP
1765 in a way their unwilling sacrifice
protects us all because if ever the
sisters were interested in performing
experiments on a larger sample size well
all we can do is hope we end up in the
control group gamma would never forget
the horrific sight of SCP
5967 on the surface she kept her nerve
cool and collected her f finger ready to
squeeze the trigger as her weapon stayed
trained on the entity but deep down it
turned her stomach after all how is
someone meant to react when they see a
thing like that a mess of Flesh and
eyeballs towering above them staring
back through more retinas than any
living creature has she did not yet know
it but she'd still be seeing that
disgusting pillar of musculature and
eyes in her nightmares for months to
come and still it wasn't even the worst
part of the incursion far worse than
seeing the 5 m tall eyeball totem
watching it blink its many Lids at her
was witnessing what it had done to Alpha
only moments before gamma's commanding
officer had been in control of this
situation leading mobile task force
Lambda 5 into the Meadowlands of East
Rutherford New Jersey the mission should
have been a simple Smash and grab the
same old boring story their team had
lived through countless times before
pick up a high value Target the leader
of yet another cult practicing an
anomalous religion and bring him in for
questioning gamma never could have
expected that things would go this badly
the task force had arrived to discover
Caesar Winters the leader of a sect of
fifths operating in New Jersey when
Lambda 5 discovered him Winters and his
followers locals who were all members of
a group known as the commune were
standing in a circle around an instance
of SCP 15
967 standing at around 5 m in height SCP
5967 were piles comprised of mostly
musculature and organs that resembled
eyeballs human eyeballs despite lacking
a mouth vocal cords or any other
conventional methods of speech these
pillars could still very much
communicate verbally although they had
little to say besides spouting phrases
and principles associated with the
fifthist ideology almost almost
immediately the plan to capture Winters
had gone aai it was almost like he
expected the foundation to arrive like
he knew they were coming as the members
of MTF Lambda 5 moved in keeping Winters
in their sights the anomalous cult
leader somehow turned the Gaze of SCP
5967 onto Alpha the team's field
commander ordered Delta to open fire
taking out Caesar Winters in a single
shot but only for a moment another of
the commune members kneeled over and
began convulsing a wound formed at the
person's neck and from it emerged Caesar
Winter's face it grew into a full-sized
head replacing that of the commune
member giving Winters a brand new body
in moments on Alpha's orders to stop
Winters from hopping to more bodies
gamma and the others in their team fired
on the other cultists everyone was
terminated 15 seconds was all it took
then they moved towards SCP
5967 and everything went wrong the
bodies started to convulse violently as
if some unseen hand was shaking them
around like ragd dolls gamma watched as
they began to levitate hoisted by their
necks and floating towards the mobile
task force not one of them knew what to
do keeping their rifles up and trained
on the corpses each one folded in on
itself becoming compressed masses of
muscle embedded with eyes that was when
the team lost Alpha something was
happening to their leader she had
dropped her weapon and Fallen to her
knees immediately gamma moved in to help
her commander trying to pull her back to
her feet but Alpha was resisting
transfixed by SCP
5967 it's her she is lost deep in the
cosmos and is angry with us for not
helping her find her way back she will
kill us all lest we line our brains and
see her for who she truly is GMA watched
as her team leaders rushed towards the
pillar of eyes and lick it the floating
orbs of Flesh and eyes that had once
been people suddenly hurdled towards the
members of MTF Lambda 5 at high speed
gamma Dove Clear at the vital moment
performing a tactical role and managing
to narrowly avoid being struck beta
wasn't so lucky ready to retaliate gamma
raises a weapon to fire at the floating
remains only to hear Alpha ordering her
to stop she had stopped licking SCP
5967 but whatever influence had
compromise the mobile task force leader
hadn't relinquished its hold over her
she grinned unnervingly as her eyes
rolled back into her head don't you hear
her voice she is angry but I can save
you I can save us let me show you ala
said before charging at GMA with her
arms outstretched in seconds before she
could defend against her commanding
officer gamma found herself pounced upon
by Alpha grabbing a nearby Rock Alpha
swung at her head and knocked gamma's
tactical helmet clean off pinning her
down possessed by some unknown anomalous
entity Alpha held open gamma's eyelids
and licked her eyeball gamma screamed in
horror as Alpha looked up to the sky and
yelled I can see you I can see
everything now the case of SCP 5967 is
one of the stranger Tales within the
animals of the SCP foundation's history
their investigation that led to the
discovery of these 5ft tall pillars of
eyes and muscle originally began with a
different intention the commune had been
making waves in Lindhurst New Jersey the
kind of waves that had caught the SCP
foundation's attention the two leaders
of this apparent cult were Salem steros
and Caesar Winters both of whom seemed
to be able to use SCP 5967 to take
control of the local residents Minds
anyone that they affected could be
controlled remotely by either steros or
Winters with a seemingly unlimited range
and no known way of relinquish ising
their control over an affected person
amnestic treatments hypnotherapy none of
the foundation's usual methods had
worked undercover Foundation operatives
working secretly within the Lindhurst
Police Department were the first to
discover an instance of SCP
5967 right under their noses literally
the pillar of eyeballs seemed to have
sprouted up right in the middle of the
lind Hurst police station the foundation
sent in containment teams to secure the
area and administer amnesty to Witnesses
but just how were steros and Winters
causing these monstrous musculature
monoliths to appear well the pair
operated a radio show together known as
the reality sync the foundation agents
within Lindhurst had been unable to
track down exactly where they were
broadcasting from however after the SCP
5967 instance appeared within the police
station the answer seemed to present
itself during the building's
reconstruction tapes of their radio show
were recover covered seeming to suggest
that the pair had been utilizing
anomalous means to broadcast the reality
sink from within the station itself
while keeping themselves concealed the
reality sync was a religious talk show
specifically focused on discussing
elements of fifth ISM with the audience
and callers who phoned into Winters and
steros hidden Studio what exactly is
fifth ISM well there's no easy answer to
that question unfortunately other
anomalous Cults and religions at least
have a cour tenant or belief at their
Center sarcasm is the worship of disease
and Decay while mechanites from the
church of the broken God venerate
technology the beliefs of the fifth
church are a little more interchangeable
however they don't really have any
defined theology or religious practices
fifth ism is often more just a
collection of recurring ideas and motifs
the number five stars and the belief in
an external Cosmic God often a malicious
one in fact if there is a defining
principle of of fifth ISM it's that it's
an anomalous way of thinking that it
can't really be understood practitioners
of fifth ISM are concerned primarily
with transcending reality as we perceive
it they are highly interested in
entities and anomalies that can warp and
shape reality to the extent of even
being fearful of such beings a lot of
fifths seek to not only spread their
influence to others through any means
necessary including brainwashing but
also hope to transcend Humanity to a
higher plane of reality The Fifth
Dimension there in theory a person would
cease to be a human being and wouldn't
even really be a kin to a god or
powerful reality Bender instead they
would become something more vague a
concept unable to be fully defined or to
exist in reality completely fius follow
this goal presumably with the intention
of saving humankind from reality warping
anomalies and they'll use any infectious
brainwashing Methods at their disposal
to bring as many people as they can into
their way of thinking this brings us
neatly back to Caesar Winters and Salem
steros Radio Show the reality sync this
was the communes their particular sect
of fifth ism's way of spreading what
they referred to as the truth based on
the various fragmented cassette
recordings of their show that the SCP
Foundation were able to recover both
steros and Winters believed in a many
armed goddess referring to it as only
she or her they encouraged their
listeners to pray to this entity and let
her know that they were loyal to her
during one of their recovered broadcasts
the pair of fifth hosts were even able
to prank call the SCP Foundation itself
one Junior researcher Jones was
contacted by the two men and ridiculed
for his association with the SCP
Foundation but after a few jokes at
Junior researcher Jones's expense steros
and Winters began to insidiously implant
ideas of fifth ISM in the researcher's
head head they referred to this as
giving Jones the truth something they
both intended to do for all of their
listeners in order to save them when
asked what they really meant Winters and
steros made vague Illusions to the truth
being an infinite knowledge that only
she could bestow Jones had no idea who
she was meant to be our Guiding Light
our creator Salem described before
adding the very thoughts that should be
infiltrating your head right now it
seemed that through this call The Two
Hosts had managed to successfully embed
their fifth Concepts into the mind of
Junior researcher Jones and they weren't
about to stop there during another call
on their show both hosts spoke with a
Wallington New Jersey resident named
Wendy Ricefield who was already a
self-proclaimed fifthist steros and
Winters talked Wendy through a ritual to
learn the truth involving her drawing
sigils on the walls and floor of her
home and lighting candles the phone line
picked up wet squelching noises coming
from the other side the Splinter string
of wood and Wendy screaming for help as
she tried to run from her home only for
something to drag her back inside
eventually the foundation made the
executive decision to step in and deal
with the situation in New Jersey
directly steros and winters's operation
was getting out of hand more and more
people in the surrounding area were
being brainwashed into believing in
fifthist Concepts and compelled to
complete bizarre rituals sending a team
in to apprehend the cult leaders
Foundation Personnel discovered Salem
steros and numerous other members of the
commune they had gathered at an instance
of SCP 5967 that had manifested in
Wallington the same place that Wendy
Ricefield had been from steros and his
Fifth's followers were discovered
holding hands and standing in a circle
around the anomalous pillar of eyeballs
as well as approaching it and licking
SCP
5967 the members of the commune were
rounded up and most were sent to be kept
in isolation at site 9 however Salem
steros was brought to site 83 for
questioning Junior researcher Umar Hadid
conducted an interview as to the exact
nature of the Goddess her that steros
and Winters often referred to and the
anomalous rituals that per had been
involved with Salem was less than
Cooperative he demanded to be set free
in the interest of saving people by
spreading the truth with Caesar however
he did reveal some key information about
her according to steros claims she was
was a goddess actively meddling with
reality and influencing human actions he
told Hadid that if he killed the junior
researcher right there it would be
because she willed it sometime before
both Salem and his cult co-leader Caesar
had been stargazing in the Meadowlands a
remote field in East Rutherford that's
when they had allegedly heard her voice
and being told the truth this reality
warping goddess was intending to return
home but that way was broken so
according to steros she needed their
help this was the reason he and Winters
began creating instances of SCP
5967 the eyeball pillars apparently
acted as beacons like a GPS signal
allowing her to come back the pair and
the rest of the commune were attempting
to prove their loyalty to her in the
hopes that they would potentially be
allowed to transcend reality in
accordance with the fifths principal
Salem steros was remained into SCP
Foundation custody and kept detained in
a containment Suite surrounded by three
Scranton reality anchors shortly after
the members of MTF Lambda 5 were
dispatched heading to the location
steros had inadvertently revealed during
his interrogation their mission was to
arrest Caesar Winters who remained at
large after the leader of Lambda 5 was
compromised eventually gamma was able to
contact the foundation who sent a
containment team as backup they secured
the surviving MTF operative along with
the infected team leader Al Alpha and
the instance of SCP 5967 on the scene
gamma was offered medical treatment and
presented with a silver lion badge for
her efforts in the field along with a
twoe vacation as a reward that did
little to stop the nightmares though she
wasn't the same and neither was Alpha
after two long weeks of psychological
screening and no further hostile or
anomalous activity Alpha was interviewed
by Junior researcher Hadid during their
discussion Alpha real Nam cassand ra
Sandy danowski described that she could
still hear voices in her head rambling
about the truth fifth ISM and eyeballs
amnestic treatment wasn't helping
suddenly someone within the foundation
played a clip of Caesar winters's voice
over the facility speakers taken from
one of his and steros radio broadcasts
it triggered an instant paranoid
reaction from Sandy followed by her
opening her mouth and revealing
something growing inside another eyeball
some kind of post- hypnotic suggestion
or other form of brainwashing had
affected her and she began exhibiting
anomalous Behavior tell me Hadid are you
a fifthist now she asked the junior
researcher are you ready to see the
truth Hadid rushed out of the room
shutting the door behind him pacing
around the room Sandy started drawing
strange sigils of Unknown Origin on the
floor and walls lighting a candle
through anomalous means then there came
a bright flash of light as a four-legged
entity appeared and attacked Alpha the
two merged causing her body to change
until it was unrecognizable well as
human anyway standing in the
interrogation room where Sandy had been
standing was a contorted mass of Flesh
and muscle with multiple eyeballs
staring out from it she had turned into
another instance of SCP
5967 they all had they were people
steros and Winters had made beacons out
of living people it happened in
1981 in a small rural Village in West
Germany s guys 9 years old ran across
the bitter snow tears freezing to his
cheeks it was Christmas Day and not long
ago he'd been so happy he was
celebrating with his family his mother
his father and his young sister the
centers of his Universe when that
monster had attacked and destroyed
everything he'd ever known the white
Terror the destroyer of Christmas cheer
the du man SCP
4666 though of course young SE fleed had
no idea in hindsight se's parents had
been noticing strange things in the
leadup to Christmas Day unfamiliar bumps
and knocks strange smells coming from
the attic the occasional tall dark
silhouette on the horizon outside their
isolated old farmhouse but in all the
hustle and bustle of the Season nobody
really paid the proper attention to all
the signs of an incoming hoist KN event
every Eerie feeling was just written off
as stress or overactive imaginations
none of the Gu Family knew about the
true danger they were facing until they
woke up to see the uan standing over
them sharpening a rusty blade and
staring at them with hungry sadistic
eyes Merry
Christmas the creature rasped and
chuckled SED was lucky to escape alive
but of course he would never see his
family again he'd be picked up a day or
so later traumatized catatonic and
almost frozen to death when he was
finally able to speak again he spoke of
a monster having killed his family when
the police investigated his home and
found the remains they deemed it to be
the work of an all to human serial
killer and poor sik fedge was entered
into the Foster system years of work
with psychiatric professionals tried to
convince young seed that the monster he
claimed to see the unnaturally tall
gnarled bony freak with those shimmering
black eyes was merely a product of his
trauma but he knew the truth he always
knew what he encountered that day the
thing that took his family was nothing
less than a true monster and at 9 years
old Sig fed made a vow he would one day
kill the monster no matter what it took
when Zid was finally adopted and
returned to school he did everything he
could to apply him himself academically
he had no interest in friends or
romantic relationships even as he grew
into his teenage years the only thing
that Drew his interest in addition to
the Perfection of his academic life was
his own private Research into the
supernatural he became an expert in all
things occultic and anomalous sightings
of ghosts Phantoms aliens and monsters
he wanted to know it all no needed to
know it all he would arm himself with
knowledge wanting to know everything he
could in advance of the confrontation
that would be his final Destiny he also
began obsessively researching attacks
similar to the ones that killed his
family and found an eerie pattern
seemingly to unfold all over the
Northern Hemisphere during the 12 Days
of Christmas entire families would be
found dead in their homes mutilated
horrifically often with children having
gone completely missing they happened
far enough apart in terms of time and
space that no connection was drawn
between the events all just random
attacks according to the police and
media weren't the connections obvious he
didn't understand it it was almost like
there was some kind of sweeping cover up
obscuring the true culprit behind all
these killings the same Beast that
destroyed his life as s freed now known
to most as Dr G ascended through his
time at University he became one of
Germany's foremost Scholars on the
occult with several published papers and
books that Drew f fascination of fellow
experts and laymen alike but most
importantly of all seek Freed's work got
the attention of the SCP Foundation they
reached out to the ambitious rising star
of the Paranormal world and offered him
a research position Dr gu was elated and
said that he would happily take the role
if they answered one question for him
did they know anything about a horrific
humanoid monster that attacked families
across the Northern Hemisphere around
Christmas time this was the moment when
Dr SEF G after Decades of searching
finally came to know about SCP
4666 he had access to all of the SCP
foundation's information on the monster
putting him several steps closer to what
had always been his ultimate goal
killing that godforsaken thing but this
would be easier said than done after all
if the uul man was easy to track the
foundation would have captured and
contained him long before now his
attacks could occur anywhere across the
Northern Hemisphere making catching him
the world's largest game of Whac-A-Mole
but this was a game that Dr guys had
more than enough patience to play over
The Following years Dr guys worked as
hard as humanly possible not just at the
case of SCP
4666 but at every piece of work the
foundation had to offer him much like
his ruined childhood guys made no effort
to interact no effort to form social
connections he just worked worked and
worked and worked and worked with
single-minded passion soon developing a
reputation as one of the most
hardworking and dependable figures in
the SCP foundation's European division
it was this kind of work ethic that soon
saw him promoted to senior researcher
and then a site director he had more
control over information resources and
Manpower than ever before it was almost
time he could sense it delegating other
tasks to his subordinates Dr gu began to
work on his Masterpiece an advanced
algorithm connecting police social media
and surveillance databases across the
Northern Hemisphere you see while Dr G
had never faltered in his quest neither
had the uul man every year more families
disappeared or were horrifically
murdered and every death weighed on guys
he saw them as a personal failing of his
of his inability to fulfill his Destiny
but the uul man was a cre creature of
habit and it would be that very
adherence to Habit that guys use to
destroy it using the algorithm he
created they would perfectly track and
triangulate the home most likely to be
the subject of a dreaded whn event with
greater accuracy and precision than ever
before the year was 2022 Dr G was
convinced that this time he would be the
one to claim victory and Vengeance there
was one thing he didn't tell his
foundation compatriots though as he put
the piece is in place for the final
showdown he had no intention of
containing the uan this time he would
destroy it using his Newfound influence
as a well-respected site director he
requested the transfer of a few
high-profile anomalies as well as the
services of a crack mobile task force
death squad it was time the uul man
watched the house from a distance he'd
been observing for days watching the
nice happy family within what pleasure
it would bring him to destroy them and
take what's left to his workshop for
further fun tonight would be the night
that he claimed them they were all
blissfully unaware and lived in an
isolated rural area where nobody but him
would hear all the wonderful screaming
the second the lights went out inside
the house he would strike and bring
about some Christmas fear when the last
window went dark the Ulan drew a long
Rusty blade out of his bag of tricks and
approached the house he crept in through
one of the windows Windows locks had
never been a problem for him this whole
process had played out hundreds of times
he barely even needed to think about it
now he crept in past the presents around
the Christmas tree found the stairs and
began to climb he'd find them in their
beds one by one and take his time
savoring the pain savoring the fear he
went into the youngest one's bedroom
first his lips pulled back into a manic
grin there was the little boy tucked in
in under his quilt like a present
waiting to be unwrapped he grabbed the
sheet with his long gnarled fingers and
pulled it back only to see a plastic
dummy underneath with a stun grenade
fixed to its chest before the uul man
could even react the stun grenade
exploded into his face blinding him with
a sudden white light and ringing in his
ancient ears the next thing he heard was
a rugged military voice yelling Squad
Alpha move in seconds later the upstairs
Landing was filled with mobile task
force operatives with assault rifles
they aimed an open fire into the uan
peppering him with painful bullets he
wasn't used to his victims fighting back
like this truthfully it even caught him
off guard but sadly for those Brave task
force operatives it would not be enough
to kill him the uan gripped his Rusty
knife and lunged at Squad Alpha moments
later they were all dead and the Furious
uan was trudging back down the stairs
there had been no satisfaction in this
Slaughter how had they caught him like
this
perhaps he'd go eat some of his servants
in his Workshop to make himself feel
better as he walked back across the
living room past the Christmas tree past
all the presence the television
flickered into life staring at him from
the screen was the grinning face of Dr
seek guys now 50 years old and the most
insane part was that the U man somehow
recognized him the one who got away 41
years prior hello old friend you're
looking a little Glam Sig freed said on
the screen I take it that you did not
enjoy the surprise party I just threw
for you don't worry the night isn't over
yet after all you haven't even opened
your presents with that the presentence
under the tree which were actually
packed with C4 plastic explosives
detonated leveling the entire house with
the uan still inside the explosion could
be heard for Miles as a great pillar of
smoke rose up into the air several
hundred M away Dr seed3 guys waited and
watched flanked by Foundation agents and
more mobile task force soldiers taking
in the Majesty of the explosion Dr gu
remained steel eyed and watched The
Blaze somehow he knew that even that
would not be enough to end the monster
permanently he nodded to the lieutenant
he'd brought with him Squad out Squad
Bravo time to engage the man barked in
response the remaining agents and MTF
operatives armed with assault rifles and
submachine guns descended on the burning
wreckage of the house moments later a
tall dark figure the uan injured but
alive crawled out of the blaze
immediately the team opened fire giving
the monster everything they had but once
again everything was not enough the
creature pulled out two long Rusty
knives and leaped Into The Fray making
short work of the foundation brass soon
enough it stood alone on bloodstained
snow until it caught another bullet in
the head Dr seed guys was standing there
The Last One Alive to face the uan
leveling a revolver the uan scalled guys
held his Ste gaze we meet again at long
last sigri said you killed my family
you've killed so many others tonight it
is your turn you man this is
your guys opened fire as the uan charged
towards him taking each shot in stride
even as the uan closed the distance G
didn't Flinch his resolve was Steely it
made the uan feel confused and Furious
that he didn't detect an ounce of fear
in this man even when he drove a knife
into the psite director's stomach seek
freed dropped to his knees and collapsed
as the uan ripped the knife back out his
gun clattered to the ground it had been
a mortal blow and still he seemed
unfazed why aren't you afraid the U man
growled Sig freed B blood and said you
took my family 41 years ago everything
since then has just been killing time
until I got to see them
again where you're going all you'll ever
see are flames and torment the uan
Furious stabbed Sig freed again this
time through the heart the doctor was
dying his life's work having seemingly
amounted to nothing but with the last of
his strength he reached into his coat
and pulled out something a little gift
he' requested from one Dr Alto cleff
before putting his plan into action Dr
seek feed guys lifted a photo of scp096
right in front of the U Man's eyes Merry
Christmas he said with his last breath
the uan was confused a photograph was
that it was that really this foolish
little boy's trump card after all this
time what a waste then without a
moment's warning scp096 barreled into
the uan sending them both rolling across
the snow one of seed's preparations was
to have SCP 96's Containment Cube
temporarily relocated to only a mile
away from the Ambush site to avoid
collateral damage if everything else
failed then scp096 would be their Hail
marry pass their finishing move and it
worked marvelously as strong and evil as
the uan was he'd been weakened by the
knight's battle and the the shy guy was
an order of magnitude more powerful than
his sadistic foe the uan screamed in
horror as scp096 set upon him with claws
and teeth after hundreds of years
inflicting it on others the uan had died
in Terror and Dr seek PL guys had died
with a smile on his face Norse mythology
tells the story of yorong Gand a Great
Serpent so long that it wraps itself the
entire way around midgard and bites its
own tail Legend says that when yorong
Gund unclasps its jaws and starts to
unfurl it will signal the beginning of
Ragnarok the destruction of the world
and that was about as much information
as the foundation gave to agent neelson
when they assigned him to his watch Duty
in Greenland in the frozen tundra all
day every day he had been equipped with
a sniper rifle thermal goggles and put
up high in a watchtower if he saw anyone
anyone he had had to shoot on site no
questions asked whether it was his
squadmates the brigadier general or even
his own mother if anyone walked across
the barren stretch of ice ahead of him
he was to shoot them dead under no
circumstances was anyone allowed to
enter that cave the fate of the world
could depend on it but it was cold and
the days were long for months he'd been
sitting there by himself without seeing
a single soul walk across the glacier
that's why it took him so long to spy
the Fig fig stumbling across the ice
half a kilometer away but the person
didn't look any clearer when agent
neelen took a look through his thermal
binoculars barely registering as much
warmer than the snow around him the man
stumbled forward seemingly unaware of
the world around him could this be the
start of the Swan Song of the world is
this what he had been warned about
without a moment's hesitation agent
neelon snatched up the sniper rifle and
readied his sights on the man somewhere
buried deep beneath the Greenland ice is
one of the most dangerous scps that the
foundation has ever come across to say
that SCP 722s Reawakening could spell
the destruction of human civilization is
no Idol concern classified as a ker
level SCP SCP 722 has been nicknamed
yund after the Norse myth researchers
speculate that the creatur's existence
could in some way be linked to the early
origins of the story of the Norse
creature 722 was brought to the
foundation's attention relatively
recently environmental activist group
Greenpeace was shooting a documentary on
the effects of global warming on
glaciers in Greenland a small crew
including a director producer three
camera operators and a sound recordist
headed out to get some close-up footage
from amongst the glaciers walking from
ice sheet to ice sheet they noticed
several rounded entrances to what looked
like deep Ice Caves surmising that these
openings were only accessible to them
because of the melting Glacier Ice the
crew climbed down into the caves to get
some never-before seen seen footage some
of the footage of their exploration has
been recovered since and in the
background of several shots as they are
adjusting exposure and pulling Focus you
can hear the producer and director
theorizing about where these caves have
come from they initially seem to think
that the caves are Millennia old
preserved by Sub-Zero temperatures but
soon they come across several markings
on the walls ancient hieroglyphs and
symbols none of the crew were language
experts and so in the footage you can
hear them struggling to identify which
people group would have carved those
into the ice walls in the decades since
language experts from around the world
have studied these markings on those
walls and have still been unable to
identify any discernable links to any
known human script most agree that it
does seem to predate the settlement of
the island by Eric the Red at the start
of the 11th century during this period
it is believed that there were no human
settlements on the island so the origins
of this script remain unknown as the
footage goes on you may start to not
notice something that the Green Piece
crew does not one of the ice walls is no
longer a wall at all it looks like a
rock in some of the footage but whenever
a flashlight Shines on its surface you
can see a pattern to it scales then an
opening at the far side of the tunnel
the crew emerges into an enormous Cavern
estimated to be upwards of 200 m in
height and several times wider even
their powerful flashlights struggle to
cut through the darkness inside that's
the point that the sound recorders
notices the scales running alongside
them as the camera pans you see that
they have been walking alongside a tail
several times taller than them a tail
that snakes its way through the darkness
of the cavern to meet a hulking mass at
the other side shrouded in darkness that
is where the footage cuts off those
green peace filmmakers were next seen in
a local town that evening none of them
had the chance to extol the wonders of
what they'd encountered that day as they
were all sick a couple went straight to
to bed in their lodgings complaining of
intense headaches and exhaustion others
tried to check themselves into the ER
but never made it each of the crew died
of different causes necrosis of the skin
internal bleeding kidney failure by 9:00
p.m. that day all of them were dead
fortunately there just so happened to be
a low-level Foundation agent staying in
the same guest house as them who heard
the commotion within 2 days a perimeter
was established within 2 years the
foundation gained the bulk of knowledge
of this SCP that they rely on to this
day it is unknown exactly how large SCP
722 actually is a hulking serpent half
buried in ice much of its body cannot be
observed it sleeps coiled up in the
middle of the cavern that the filmmakers
happened across some of its body is
buried beneath fallen in parts of the
caves others frozen into the ground
around it however based on what can be
observed of this SCP it is estimated to
be in the ranges of 8 to 12 12 km from
head to tail fortunately for just about
everyone including you this SCP appears
to be dormant and no time since its
Discovery has this SCP been observed to
move make a sound or otherwise indicate
Consciousness sensors are installed in
the chamber to monitor its life
functions and study its heart rate
temperature brain activity and more one
concern to the foundation is that since
its Discovery 722 has had a 9% uptick in
neural activity researchers hope that
this is just a natural part of the sleep
cycle and that it will return to a
deeper Slumber soon that is the hope at
least so what makes this SCP so
dangerous then if it's sound asleep well
let's go back to agent neelon steering
through the scope of his rifle the
barrel kicked back a puff of warm smoke
there and gone in cold air he watched
just long enough to confirm the kill
before radioing back to command what he
had observed within an hour the cleanup
crew arrived D riding on snowmobiles
they waited at a distance for an hour
before approaching the body rather
unceremoniously they wrapped it up in a
black plastic bag strapped it to the
back of their snowmobile and took it
away for cremation neelen just sat there
in his Watchtower the whole time
observing it all the person looked sick
and not the kind of sick that you'd get
from spending too much time out there on
the ice their skin had gone rotten like
they had gang greine or leprosy it
wasn't just your usual frostbite most
concerning they'd been wearing a
jumpsuit standard issue for d-class
personnel only a vial held in their cold
dead fingers was any kind of clue for
neelen as to what had been going on in
that cave but that was as close as the
agent ever came to understanding the
mysteries of SCP 722 the vial however
was in many ways all he needed to know
that is because contained in that vial
was a sample of the liquid secreted by
722 it is a liquid that the Green Piece
crew came into close contact with when
they found the creature and it's a
liquid that promises and denies great
power and great risk to the foundation
any and all attempts to study this
liquid in any meaningful sense have
failed anyone who comes into contact
with it will immediately suffer acute
sickness interestingly however there
seems to be little consistency as to how
this sickness manifests itself some
develop a number of cancerous cells
whilst others lose cognitive function
due due to brain swelling symptoms seem
to vary from person to person naturally
this makes studying the substance very
difficult hazardous material suits have
been deployed for researchers attempting
to study it but have all failed despite
being otherwise effective against
chemical biological and radioactive
threats how the substance is able to
infect them is unknown sadly a good
number of scientists had to die to make
this discovery another route of study is
to take the substance out of the cave
and observe it under laboratory
conditions this was what agent neelon
observed as he shot and killed the
d-class Personnel emerging from the Cave
the d-class had been sent in to retrieve
the vial of the substance for external
study while a safe and direct route of
entry and exit had been planned for the
man to take he became critically ill
whilst in contact with 722 and developed
an aggressive fever no longer coherent
over the radio he dropped out of signal
wandering through the tunnels for 2
hours until emerging out of an exit high
up on the glacier two agents with higher
security clearance were dispatched to
deal with the body the reason for their
waight was for their own safety 7 22's
toxin appears to denature with time away
from its source causing it to weaken in
potency if they had approached
immediately they may have well suffered
similar Fates to the d-class they
survived but the sample was ruined all
subsequent attempts have also been met
with failure it seems almost impossible
to capture a clean sample and transport
it any kind of distance with this toxin
the foundation would have possession of
an immense biological weapon akin to the
discovery of the atom bomb but as of
right now all it's good for is killing
d-class Personnel initially the
foundation believed the fluid to be a
defense mechanism for the SCP something
to protect it in its deep sleep but the
more time is spent observing it the more
time this perception is Shifting SCP
722s toxin appears instead to be a
weapon as such the containment of this
creature is of Paramount importance
there are eight known access points into
the tunnel Network that would Grant
access to SCP 722 each of them has been
sealed with reinforced gates with
additional layers of soundproofing at
regular 4-Hour intervals nitrogen gas
cooled to a near liquid state is to be
pumped through these doors without fail
it is believed that the creature is a
form of Proto reptile and so is
theoretically coldblooded its internal
temperature is dict ated by its
surroundings therefore by keeping a cool
average temperature in these caves it is
thought that this SCP Slumber can be
prolonged how long is unclear with
Rising global temperatures year after
year the threat that the Greenpeace
activists were proclaiming is very real
just perhaps not quite in the way they'd
envisioned Not only would there be an
increase in natural disasters and a
decrease in biodiversity there would
also be a 12 km snake roaming around the
planet killing any one in its path not
ideal as such the foundation has also
planted a number of Highly skilled
individuals in prominent environmental
positions in the hopes of turning the
tide of global warming sooner should the
ice in that cave system warm by even a
couple of degrees who knows what kind of
Spike they might see on the neural
monitors this SCP naturally is buried
deep beneath layers and layers of
security clearances too only in
exceptional circumstances and for Vital
maintenance is anyone allowed to
approach this SCP a minimum of two level
three clearance agents are required to
sign off on any such Works in recent
years a new Brigadier General took
charge of the containment operations of
SCP 722 after his predecessor was
stripped of his duties overly zealous
experiments and increasingly desperate
attempts to harvest or synthesize the
722 toxin saw an alarming uptick in
neural activity over 40 d-class
Personnel were processed and disposed of
within a 2 we period in an attempt to
assemble a micro laboratory within the
main chamber itself this project failed
and the noises of construction
threatened the peace that had so long
been maintained beneath the glacier the
new Brigadier General is taking no such
risks enforcing a zero tolerance policy
on anyone approaching site 103 unless
suitably cleared a number of hikers have
sadly had to be killed this way but the
foundation believes it to be a necessary
sacrifice to keep the peace it is quite
easy to find a convincing backstory for
their untimely deaths and the lack of
bodies to bury just another person to
get lost and fall down a crack in the
glacier warning stories that are shared
and planted in local towns and on the
internet the only threat to this current
piece is a new Avenue of inquiry that
researchers have stumbled across a link
to a group of animals found halfway
around the world monitor lizards of the
genus varanus seem to share a similar
set of traits to SCP 722 namely the
nature of their toxins you may be
familiar with the bite of a kodo dragon
while the initial wound sure does hurt
the real damage comes in the following
hours and days as necrosis sets in from
the toxins in its mouth could these
creatures share a common ancestor could
722 be the common ancestor as of right
now it is just a hunch but it's one that
has taken root amongst the research
staff in order to find out more though
they need samples tissue samples taken
straight from the SCP itself the only
way to do back is to go back into the
caves and start cutting if a bit of
construction noise was enough to raise
brain activity by .9% taking a hunk of
Flesh could prove a whole lot more
dangerous not least for the Personnel
involved who will all have to sacrifice
their lives the potential benefits could
be huge a way to study fatal diseases in
a new light perhaps finding a way to
reverse engineer cures to some of the
deadliest conditions on the planet or
perhaps the missing ingredient to
synthesizing the most powerful
biological weapon in human history maybe
worst of all it could all trigger The
Reawakening do you remember how the
story of yorong gundur ends with a
prediction that when the Great Serpent
un coils the end of the world Ragnarok
itself will arrive but that's just an
old fairy tale right the helicopter
lurched and rumbled as it made its
descent through the veran insk mountain
range condition s were harsh with Fierce
winds ripping Through The Valleys at any
point a blizzard threatened to strike
just about managing to touchdown mobile
task force Lambda 9 was glad to be out
of the vehicle even if it meant stepping
into kneee snow there were eight
operatives in total early reconnaissance
suggested that they were the only people
present within a 5 km radius at least
that's certainly what they hoped L9
operatives 1 through six all made their
way way up through the mountain pass
leaving seven and eight guarding the
chopper this was a simple reconnaissance
mission they would need to search the
bunker for any signs of Life gather
Intel and get out hopefully before the
snowstorm hit all eight of them were
kitted out with the foundation's kter
grade Cutting Edge anti- cionic plating
the operatives had all been chosen
carefully with l91 the leader being an
experienced Soldier serving 11 years in
the unit he had capable pionic Powers
himself and approached L 9-2 who showed
some of the same gifts all of a sudden
as the group rounded the final pass and
caught sight of the facility both one
and two experienced severe migraines
battered by the Russian wind they had no
choice but to get to the bunker as fast
as possible it looked relatively
unassuming a small concrete slab sitting
amongst the mountains the six of them
gathered around on either side of the
doors as number three forced his way
inside following standard breaching
Maneuvers the rest of the team followed
suit charging in through the open
doorway and immediately tipping forward
into an abyss they all landed hard side
by side on the slope some of them
rolling down clattering against each
other and eventually skidding to a stop
very gingerly the groups started to get
back to their feet and catch their
breath as the wind had been knocked out
out of all of them they weren't in a
research facility at all the Soviet
concrete walls they hadd been expecting
the old computers and the lab equipment
were all missing instead they were
standing in a void infinite and white
with no seeming end in any direction
beneath their feet and curling up above
them was an enormous double helix a
rainbow of colors weaving in and out of
one another it was like they had found
themselves standing on an enormous
strand of DNA floating all around them
were glowing orbs of light none of them
could tell how near or far these orbs
were they could have been close enough
to reach out and touch or they could
have been on the other side of the
universe and slowly one by one they
noticed the doorway that they had come
in through it was perpendicular to the
double helix and floating about 3 m
above their heads through it they could
see the snowy Russian Mountains their
only chance of Escape four murmured
something about needing to leave one
argued back at him they had no idea
whether that door was real or an
illusion they had no idea if if they
would even be able to pass through it
besides it was 3 m above their heads and
floating out over the void it was risky
but for didn't care much about receiving
permission taking a few steps back
further down the double helix to get a
good runup he braced himself and
sprinted as fast as he could before
jumping and reaching for the open
doorway it was as if gravity was
suddenly much stronger as soon as he
stepped off the double helix four was
wrenched downwards tumbling and spinning
accelerating faster and faster
he let out a petrified scream that sent
the other operatives cowering there was
no bottom at least not as far as they
could see or here for's body just got
smaller and smaller and his screams
quieter and quieter for several minutes
until the agents couldn't hear him
anymore and yet inside the heads of one
and two the psionic members of the group
that screaming sound only seemed to grow
louder December 25th
1962 a man walked briskly through the
West Berlin train station he' shaved his
head the night before and trimmed his
beard down to a thick mustache dark
sunlasses covered his eyes and a fedora
was tipped forward he hoped that his
limp was convincing as he shuffled his
way through the crowds one advantage of
wearing dark sunglasses in the middle of
winter was that he could constantly scan
the faces of those around him looking
for anybody who looked Russian his train
had been delayed an hour outside of
Berlin the train had ground to a halt
German police officers had walked the
length of the carriages checking
everyone's tickets and passports it felt
like an eternity the man was too old by
this point to attempt to run away
besides running through rural Germany in
the snow didn't sound like the best plan
so he stuck to his cover story and hoped
against hope that the fake passport he
bought would be convincing enough
fortunately for him the officer checked
it he looked to be about 18 years old
the man doubted that the boy would know
a Russian passport if it was signed by
Nikita kushev himself but shuffling
through the station his feeling of
unease grew Russian deserters had been
poisoned all around him for the prior 15
years a number of his own colleagues had
mysteriously gone missing after feeling
disenfranchised by the Soviet agenda it
was such a high-profile Target that
there was no way the KGB wasn't actively
hunting him down at that very moment he
clutched the briefcase tightly and made
his way way out of the station his plan
had been to call a taxi but now the
prospect of being alone in an anonymous
vehicle with only one other person
terrified him his best protection would
be to stay out in the open as much as
possible he would walk to the British
Embassy or rather he'd pretend to limp
there Lambda 9 operatives number seven
and 8 stood by the helicopter shivering
their team had been missing for hours
now and they could see the blizzard
slowly covering the mountain rang like a
blanket before long it would reach them
if their helicopter got buried by
anything more than a couple of inches
all hopes of evacuating back to base
would be dashed as soon as their team
had gone through the doors into the
facility all radio contact with them had
been cut off the foundation had
suspected that the bunker would be
heavily insulated but if that were the
case surely one of them would have
stepped outside to resume radio contact
and report what they had found so far
then all of a sudden went limp he
remained standing but his head and
shoulders slumped forward as if he'd
fallen asleep perhaps he had been
standing out here for too long eight was
about to Rouse him when suddenly seven
started talking hello eight can you hear
me it's one are you there the
conversation moved quickly somehow one
had been able to reach out to Seven's
mind and temporarily take control in
order to use him as a mouthpiece to
communicate with the foundation over the
radio this kind of contact would
normally have been well beyond what one
would have been capable of but he
explained that as soon as they had
entered the facility both he and two had
felt their powers growing immeasurably
the foundation asked for a situation
report and one updated them about what
had happened to four trying to escape
through the door he jumped and fell
through the abyss but what was more
sickening was that they had seen for
again all of a sudden they had started
to hear his screams physically not
psionically and he had fallen past them
just off to their right almost with
within touching distance having decided
that it was too risky to attempt an
escape as four had done the group of
them made the decision to travel further
down into the facility descending along
the Helix for the next 3 hours s is
unresponsive he stands there limp in the
snow hunched forward and not speaking
despite eight and the foundation's best
attempts to wake him command we found
something the Helix branches off a bit
there's a doorway there I can see inside
it looks like a lab of some kind we can
walk to it hopefully it's a way out
command sent authorization for them to
proceed and so they did one reported
that it appeared that they were back in
the real world the abstract shapes and
colors the infinite void was gone they
were in a Soviet research lab there was
medical equipment everywhere syringes
and jars full of well maybe it's best
not to know what was in them as Lambda 9
walked through the facility checking
every corner before rounding out they
felt a profound sense of unease surely
enough that feeling was warranted
rounding the corner one found some human
remains the man appeared to have been a
researcher at one point his brains were
now stretched out and stuck to the walls
like Silly Putty what the hell happened
here safely on British soil the man who
had defected from the Soviet Union sat
in the interview room chewing his bottom
lip he had spent so much time focusing
on how he would escape with his life
that he hadn't spared much thought for
what he would say say once he was on the
other side they had codenamed him Iceman
but he didn't feel particularly cold at
that moment he felt nervous but he did
his best to hide it I was a project
manager in the psychotronics division of
the main intelligence directorate I
oversaw project Redline which was
commissioned by Joseph Stalin following
the second world war and before he knew
what he was doing he told his
interviewer everything over 20 million
Soviets had died during the second World
War their death toll eclipsed that of
any other country Iceman had witnessed
it all so when Stalin had come to him
with the task of creating an ultra
powerful psychic weapon something that
could convert the entire world
population to adopt Marxism leninism the
man had his reservations activating a
device like that could trigger a war
even deadlier than either of the two
already experienced that Century he was
part of Gru division P the Russian arm
of Highly classified experiment Al
research conferring with his team they
devised a plan they would argue they
needed absolute secrecy to carry out
their work even away from the watching
eyes of the KGB rather than create a
weapon they would create a tool for
peace instead of promoting the values of
Communism they would create a psychic
tool to dampen Humanity's inclination
towards violence and aggression their
method would be brutal but un necessary
evil in short their theory was the
psychic mind is often limited by the
human body a young child could have
incredible psychic potential but their
physical limitations would hold them
back from exercising it therefore they
needed to separate mind from body and
they had just the trick for that
traumatic disassociation they would take
a young gifted psychic and tear out
their mind in order to transfer that
mind into the body of a controllable
Avatar Iceman explained that none of
them could have expected how much fate
would look favorably on them just 2
years prior the KGB had captured and
brought in a set of triplets for them
the triplets were incredibly rare
conjoined at both the head and the Torso
with three arms and six legs it was a
miracle they were still alive so Iceman
and his team set to work immediately
they dosed the triplets up with as many
mind-altering chemicals as they could
physically endure before electrocuting
them for prolonged periods whilst
reading antiv violent manifestos to them
it worked the trip minds disassociated
and the Soviets were able to capture it
Iceman was not forthcoming about what
they did with the mind or where they
transferred it all he explained was that
it worked they took the weapon to the
norog gulag 50,000 of the most vicious
criminals known to man Luthers murderers
Psychopaths dropped their makeshift
knives and refused to move an inch even
as we threw the gates of the camp wide
open we did that the final test was on
Nikita Kev and John F Kennedy from
thousands of kilometers away they
activated project Redline and influenced
the two world leaders at the height of
the Cuban Missile Crisis war was averted
but crev was Furious he removed the
entire team killing a number of them and
began to weaponize project Redline if
they could fire it at an advancing Army
they'd never lose a single soldier ever
again to do this it needed to be
stronger they were to implant the
Consciousness into another subject
torture them further and disassociate
again simplifying the psychic abilities
mobile task force Lambda 9 were stuck in
the facility the blizzard had been so
strong that seven and 8 had to return to
base the previous night and come back
having spent a night lost in wandering
through the Helix descending deeper and
deeper the team had noticed that the
world around them was getting darker
periodically they could hear Force
screaming and falling past them once
again before dropping out of sight again
beneath them they had tried to catch him
to pull him back but he was always just
Out Of Reach desperate to be saved seven
and 8 returned and their psychic puppet
radio contact was resumed with command
the team found another door searching
through it they were horrified to find
their own corpses floating in the air in
front of them dressed up in lab coats
just like the scientists from the levels
above them their brains were stretching
out and lying together in some kind of
web yet further down the Helix they
found another door one and three decided
to go inside leaving the rest of the
team standing on the Helix ready to
catch four if fell past again this time
two was in contact with command through
his psychic link to the men by the
chopper he soon reported hearing for his
screams getting closer and closer the
group stood around ready to catch him
there he is I can see him he's
definitely Falling Towards us yeah see
it too command there's something up with
for it looks like he's spread eagled his
arms are stretched out he's he's
screaming it's not getting louder it's
getting flatter there would be no
further contact with two five and six by
the time 1 and three were returned from
scouting out the room they were alone
one couldn't even sense the presence of
any of their squadmates anymore they had
no option but to continue to descend the
Helix into the darkness the smell of
burning flesh filled their noses The
Echoes of death were all around them
voices cried out in pain and fear and
then new voices speaking in Russian cut
over the top stop it give in don't
resist resisting is bad you will be if
you resist begin electrical discharge
500 volts 3 amps increase voltage every
minute the operatives had no choice but
to listen to the memory of the triplets
being tortured not just the sounds but
the emotions that flood them those
weren't someone else's memories anymore
they were becoming their own and just as
they saw into the mind of the triplets
the triplet saw them in return command
it's trying to open me up like it did
everyone else but I can see into it it's
learning from us it knows all about me
the squad the foundation they're almost
on me it's it's the conjunction the
scientists the monsters that made this
thing the ones it knew before it died
was that they wanted it to conjunct it
wants to make us part of it don't come
back here it wants to make the whole
world part of it and at that moment the
entirety of mobile task force Lambda 9
dropped dead in that same moment a
multicolored sphere of energy 5 km wide
appeared over the facility dwarfing the
mountains around it designated SCP 2664
daa for years the foundation dropped
psionically dampening materials and
psionically stumped d-class Personnel
into the sphere in hopes of slowing its
growth no other containment measures
could be acted upon that was until 1300
hours on the 25th of December 2000
Christmas Day SCP 2664 daa suddenly
fluctuated releasing an enormous amount
of psionic energy that resulted in the
brain death of all humans within a 200
km radius the following day at 1700
hours a global cult Coalition satellite
launched a spherical payload right into
the heart of SCP 2664 D for 13 minutes
tremendous amounts of radiation were
detected emanating from inside the
sphere before just as suddenly as it had
appeared SCP 2664 daa disappeared
entirely leaving just the payload in its
place before the foundation was able to
recover the payload it launched into the
atmosphere and was lost subsequent
reconnaissance operations to the site
have confirmed no abnormal radioactive
or psionic readings to all intents and
purposes SCP 2664 appears to be gone as
such the file has been marked as
neutralized long may it stay that way
stop right up folks we've got all kinds
of refreshing and tasty traits here for
you today popcorn corn peanuts cotton
candy and even fried dough yeser here at
SCP explain we're offering the
top-of-the-line anomalous delectible
food stuffs for all your circus themed
Funtime occasions and that's because
today yes today on this YouTube platform
our Infamous acronym doesn't stand for
secure contain protect it stands for
sweet confectionary products and let me
tell you dear viewer the SCP we're
looking at today just might be the most
decadent durable and dangerous dessert
that's ever desired to be devoured we're
talking about SCP
377 or as they are better known the
sugar Golems these little fellas are
safe class and also totally harmless so
long as you take the proper precautions
what's the matter don't you believe me
don't you think it's nice of us to cover
a safe SCP now and again and hey now why
all this dull talk about rules and
regulations in the first place you don't
go out to the carnival to not take wild
and exciting risks every spinny twirly
and whirly ride on the fairgrounds comes
with a statistically higher chance of a
tragic mishap befalling you and any
other Thrill Seekers around you but we
all take that chance anyway for the
extraordinary Rush of the experience and
such is the wacky and wonderful ways of
our adorable and questionably edible
Chums the sugar Golems don't you just
love them folks ain't they a sight for
sore eyes and a pay for sweet teeth well
we're only just getting started the best
is yet to come ladies and notd ladies so
pull up a chair and be sure to watch
what we've got in store you can make
like a piece of old candy and stick
around now that's a KNE slapper ain't
it sit back relax and make sure to enjoy
the show you should also subscribe to
SCP explained if You' like to continue
to be entertained hey that rhy what do
you know I'm a boat and I didn't even
know it out roll well SCP 377 refers to
the anomalous substance contained in
site 81 the semi-humanoid instances
which are nicknamed sugar Golems are
themselves an animate and independent
byproduct that naturally spawns from a
CP 377 when it is allowed to exist
outside of containment procedures the
most important of these containment
procedures being that SCP 377 must
remain at a constant temperature of well
below its freezing point and only be
stored in containers full to capacity
less its aformentioned byproducts
attempt to breach containment the total
volume of SCP 3077 within the cryogenic
containment unit equals almost
2200 L and it is believed to be the only
known quantity of the anomalous
substance in existence for the sake of
clarity in distinguishing between SCP
3077 and its byproducts we'll be
referring to the main object contained
by the foundation as SCP 3077 while the
gooey little guys who we know to
spontaneously split off from the source
of SCP 3077 will be regarded as SCP 3077
1 as mentioned before SC SCP 3771
instances have been affectionately
dubbed the sugar Golems every instance
of SCP 30771 resembles an approximately
1 M tall gaunt humanoid composed of a
pure sugar derived substance commonly
known as prle and that's meiosis for all
y'all yea Cowboys over there in the US
OFA if you've ever played the classic
board game Candyland you'll have some
idea of what an individual instance of a
CP 3077 looks like from the Beloved and
often remembered character of Gloppy who
lives in the Molasses swamp section of
the board and is also fittingly made out
of molasses himself yes indeed Gloppy is
truly a delight for a weary Candyland
player to meet what did you say are you
folks too young to know about Candyland
well that factoid certainly makes this
narrator feel pretty old then again I am
taking on the mannerisms and attire of
an old-fashioned Carnival Barker so I
suppose a bit of Novel antiquity comes
with the
territory regardless the Golems are each
composed of roughly 7 lit of sweet
syrupy goodness and very much like
everyone's favorite character Gloppy
they all lack toine lower bodies and can
all emote through crude yet oddly
endearing vocalizations in the place of
intelligible speech while their facial
features are simplistic and misshapen
the Contours of concave eyes and gaping
mouth are usually present the exact
number of these eyes and mouths is
subject to variation much like the color
of the B spaces in a wonderful wholesome
family game of Candyland while each SC
SCP 30771 instance is around the same
size the body proportions and overall
shape of each instance are rather fluid
pun fly intended some possess oversized
arms or bulbous heads While others might
be conjoined to an adjacent sugar golum
as if to show that the two are
inseparable as a pair of best buddies or
as some others might put it a couple of
BFFs best friends for fancy frolicking
they really are quite friendly looking
aren't they and aren't they they sure
are for the only thing that these sugary
sweet SCP instances want is to be in the
company of human beings just like you
yes you who else will I be talking to
it's a hard life for this warn down
Connie let me tell you these little
sugar Golems love what they do and do
what they love but that doesn't mean
that it's time for Fun and Games even
though SCP 3771 instances want to hang
around human beings they don't tend to
stop at hey and hello or whatever those
appropriate Gittings sound like when
they are being gurgled by a dimunitive
molten Trier monster things can get out
of hand real fast just like an orange
cream popsicle melting in the sun of a
late summer's day now listen up it's
important that you pay attention to what
I say next I'm about to book learn you
about what to do if an instance of SCP
30771 enters your personal space the
results of prolonged contact with this
SCP can end badly if if you're not
careful I'm not going to sugarcoat any
of the chewy details of your Grizzly
fate and I promise that it won't be a
cakewalk so don't be a nerd and listen
up yes that's right I called you a nerd
you know like nerds the candy how do you
folks seriously not know nerds they were
classic Halloween candy from the Wonka
company and they were very popular back
in the day oh what's that you say how
long ago was it back in the day for me
that's a bit of a root question wouldn't
you say oh I won't you go ahead and
knock it off with the Wise Guy questions
what are are you a pack of
Smarties I said Smarties get it just
like that ah never mind let's just move
on to the explanation of how to survive
a close encounter with this SCP that was
the main reason you came all this way to
this here educational and entertaining
video presentation after all to pick up
where I left off instances of SCP 30771
have a tendency to seek out nearby human
life the reason for doing so is
surprisingly simple and alarmingly well
alarming these sticky sacin simulakra
are solely set on slithering into
people's mouths for the purposes of
gaining total control of their bodies
Yes you heard that right believe it or
not the same anomalous property which
animates the sugar Golem freal bodies is
apparently capable of overriding the
human nervous system from the inside and
that's no joke folks while these tasty
treats might sound sweet to eat you'll
be a puppet of meat from your head to
your feet if you don't complete the
tasks I intreat if an instance of SCP
30771 attempts to enter your mouth you
must remember first and foremost to keep
your trap shut blocking it with a mask
or a similar article of clothing if need
be next you must use your limbs and all
available implements to batter the
attacking Golem away while you do your
best to keep a distance of at least Arms
Reach between yourself and the instance
it should come as a relief to our
rational people that SCP 30771 instances
are severely limited in their physical
capabilities and an adult human of
average fitness can easily hold one off
if they know what to expect the tricky
part comes from the amorphous properties
of the instance's viscous pral bodies as
well as their anomalous ability to
regenerate from any physical trauma the
only way to permanently destroy an
instance of SCP
30771 is to expose it to temperatures
above its melting point which for you
sticklers out there is approximately
what
176° C the most effective weapons
against SCP 3771 instances include fire
bombs flamethrowers and your
run-of-the-mill convection ovens if it
is at all possible to contain the
instance within a sealed vessel such as
a large Tupperware or wooden barrel then
you ought to do whatever you can to
prevent the candy creeps from running a
mck while ordinary below zero
temperatures are unable to destroy the
anomalous trial of SCP 3077 in instances
of SCP
3771 can effectively be slowed down or
stopped completely if you put them on
Ice whether it's the hot foot or the
cold shoulder some form of extreme
temperature should always be weaponized
when defending oneself from an SCP 30771
instance any attempt to crush or smash
an SCP 30771 instance will only result
in the bad bon bon breaking apart and
reforming into several more belligerent
bite-sized blighters I human Under Siege
by the sugar Golems might find
themselves quickly outnumbered if they
foolishly attempt to use a melee weapon
against the anomalies basically it's
like a more delicious version of the
popular arcade video game asteroids no
eh I guess that reference was from
before even my time at any rate
instances of SCP 30771 are difficult to
destroy without access to heat or
freezing the tendency of the Molasses
menaces to increase in number is made
even worse because of the fact that any
amount ount of SCP 3077 outside of
containment can generate a nearly
infinite number of SCP
30771 while even an army of SCP 30771
instances is far weaker than an
equivalent pack of hunting animals the
ability to continuously multiply and
Physiology that doesn't experience the
consequences of fatigue means that given
enough time these sugar Golems can
Outlast any amount of human resistance
until they roll over their preferred
prey like a slow insurmountable syrupy
tsunami of surrender seriously scary
stuff someone say but what happens next
is the real kicker folks mind this
balo's somber Spiel if an instance of
SCP 30771 manages to Against All Odds
clamber its way into a human chat box
and hijack the poor Sap's nervous system
the victim is immediately classified as
SCP
377-2 SCP 377-2 instances are easily
distinguished from unaffected humans on
site h
dark tendrils of SCP 3077 can be seen
visibly moving beneath the skin and
often emerge from the mouth to
crisscross the instance's face like
makeup the world's most disturbing
circus clown that's not all after the
tragic Tri transformation takes place
the movements exhibited by the instance
of SCP
377-2 will become crooked and Jerky like
a marionette puppeteered by a frustrated
chimpanzee during this time the instance
remains fully conscious containing
whatever cognitive faculties it has
possessed previous to its classification
but it is unable to attempt speech or
exert autonomy over its own actions this
fun fact was discovered by studying the
EEG recordings of several SCP 377-2
instances and is brought to you by the
United Guild of the existentially
terrified if an instance of SCP 377-2
happens to wander its way into the
vicinity of any humans that haven't
succumbed to the process of consuming
SCP 30 77-1 it will proceed to put on a
JY performance for its new found
audience this peculiar display involves
clumsy efforts at dance choreography and
the throaty singing of unsettling atonal
Melodies that would make your annoying
cousins road trip songs sound like their
in tune these awkward performances
continue until the audience departs from
the view of SCP 377-2 instance or the
instance expires this confirms that the
point of the gesture is to entertain as
without an audience the SCP 377-2
instance is not compelled to make any
noises of its own accord and in general
doesn't do anything other than move
around aimlessly in the event that any
number of scp3 77-1 instances escapes
from containment and causes the creation
of SCP
377-2 members of the mobile task force
are instructed to never stray from the
line of sight of a currently performing
SCP 377-2 instance and to approach it
steadily before for restraining the
instance while causing minimal harm to
the body SCP 377-2 instances can be
useful for running further tests on the
anomalous properties of SCP 3077 and
there are simple procedures that allow
an instance to be kept alive
indefinitely in containment any damage
sustained during capture can severely
hamper the efficiency of these life
sustaining procedures the worst case
scenario is that an SCP 377-2 instance
expires before being securely contained
as will cause the SCP 30771 instance to
emerge from its host and resume its
Relentless attack on all nearby humans
it is far easier to Simply deal with SCP
377-2 instances accordingly and this is
because SCP
377-2 only ever attempts to continue the
performance and possesses neither the
intention nor the capacity for
retaliation if it is deemed necessary
for the effectiveness of a recapture
effort it can be permiss ible for the
mobile task force to allow instances of
SCP 30771 outside of containing to find
purchase within SCP
377-2 to increase the ease of
containment and lessen the risk of
foundation Personnel being affected the
performances of SCP 377-2 instances are
rarely physically intensive enough to
make capture too difficult but it can be
said that the Whimsical antics of these
affected humans are anything but
predictable during some rare and special
performances and if the SCP 30771
instance in control of SCP 377-2
instance is feeling especially daring it
may try to show off an array of woefully
inadequate acrobatic skills front flips
that are more like belly flops back
flips that could be mistaken for pret
Falls and the sort of dioo P trap acts
that are better left to the imagination
in lie of Prior incident the foundation
strongly advises that if for any reason
an instance of SCP 377-2 must exist in
containment it must always be prevented
from being at an altitude of more than 6
ft from the surface of the floor
especially if any humans it would
perceive as an audience are located
directly beneath where its performance
would take place regarding the creation
of further instances of SCP
377-2 requests from any level of
foundation Personnel at site 81 or
elsewhere must be granted permission to
proceed by SCP 3077 head resar
because of the horrific implications of
what happens to the still aware human
mind while the body is affected by SCP
30771 this process is only to be
approved for use on d-class Personnel
that's right and even then in the event
that all the rigar of the paperwork goes
through it is not acceptable to create
an instance of SCP
377-2 merely for the purpose of
providing live entertainment to fellow
researchers after all not a single one
of should be quick to forget the
grotesque and highly regrettable
spectacle that was Dr deetz's deplorable
d-class dancers every researcher
involved with that ethical nightmare was
reprimanded severely and the colorful
novelty costumes and jangling bells that
all former d-class Personnel were made
to wear after being reclassified to SCP
377-2 have been permanently confiscated
let the cotton candy machine and peanut
dispenser located just outside the
containment unit of SCP 3077 serve as a
a St reminder that there's a time and
place for Monkey Shines and Tom Foolery
and sometimes yes even now and then a
highly secure Foundation facility is
neither the right place nor the right
time in case you haven't picked up on it
there are very few practical
applications of SCP 3077 due to the fact
that its status as a food dish is
negated by the consequences of
consumption the main reason for tests to
be administered on SCP 377-2 instances
is to discover if there is is a safe
method of extracting an SCP 30771
instance from the body of its host
without causing the expiration of the
original human unfortunately due to a
persistent lack of success the
experiments have been discontinued
indefinitely but that just won't do how
else are we supposed to know if these
things actually taste as good as they
look I won't rest until everyone is able
to harmlessly ingest a sugar Golem of
their very own I might be oldfashioned
but to me the safe object class isn't
just a designation it's an
invitation I ought to be completely okay
doing whatever I like around a safed
object because it's safe that word
should actually mean something ding ding
darn it and I don't mean that in the
sense that the SCP Foundation uses it
meaning an anomaly that doesn't present
an active threat to containment efforts
and more importantly there aren't that
many anomalies that are also delicious
candy and I want to eat this one sorry
sorry sorry I lost my coolit there I
just have a sweet to tooth and my brain
is constantly drifting back to my
nostalgic childhood memories of playing
Candyland with my family that was before
they all decided that they wanted
nothing to do with me because I became
so obsessed with dressing up like a
Carnival Barker that I drove away
everyone who's ever cared about me other
than that my job here at the foundation
explaining confectionary scps is the
only thing I have left in my sad sad
life some days I feel less like Gloppy
and more like a real lord licorice in
Hard Times Like These a fellow could
really use some entertainment to cheer
himself up wait just a flee jumping
moment what was that that's the big idea
how did these escaped instances of SCP
377-2 get in here they're all supposed
to be in safe containment a few floors
down did somebody else from the research
team let them in here because they knew
I was in costume standing in front of a
for 10 Fairground set that's in pretty
poor taste don't you think pun very much
intended I should probably report it to
the head researcher that would be the
ethical reasonable thing to do then
again look at them go those are ier some
hilarious dances I'm definitely seeing a
Snappy attempt at doing the Charleston
uh classic and is that one doing the
worm or is it just kind of flopping on
the floor I think one of these instances
knows about that fortnite stuff all the
kids are into these days but I'm not
sure if the human element or the gollem
that decides what dances it knows either
way this was exactly what I needed to
feel so much better for once it feels
like I'm actually at a carnival instead
of just pretending to be at one now this
is the greatest performance I've ever
seen in all my years which you can be
sure that there have been a lot of the
tiny carnivorous snowmen are Relentless
sharp fangs dripping with blood as they
crawl unmas towards the mobile task
force opening fire on them with their
assault rifles who would have guessed
that a mere hour or two earlier a young
boy was joyfully playing around in the
snow here how had things gone from
Frosty to freaky so fast let's re rewind
the clock there was a chill in the air
that lingering biting cold that would
gnaw your Exposed Skin if you dared to
step outside in anything less than a
thick warm coat for protection the
ground was still coated in a heavy
snowfall a hold over from Christmas just
passed weather that had refused to let
up well into the early days of the New
Year everyone reaches an age where the
sinicism of Life the weight of
expectations that keep you anchored in
the real world they all coales to rob
you of the childlike wonder of the snow
as you get older the snow loses its
novelty it becomes a source of
inconvenience something that you need to
shovel off the driveway to take your car
out whereas turn the clock back to Youth
and it's like a tiny Miracle It Coats
your whole world in a clean blanket of
freezing Frost turning the ordinary into
a Wonderland Robert and Michaela
Anderson were glad that their son
Michael was still at an age where he
could enjoy the the snow after all
Michaela getting to take her son out in
the sled or seeing him hurling snowballs
at Robert was able to provide them with
a little bit of warmth during the
freezing cold snowier months in Missouri
optimism was never enough to melt the
snow however and maybe that's what drew
in those creatures the snowmen it was
early 2019 not even a full 2 weeks into
the Year by now Michael had gotten used
to the fact that after Christmas and New
Year's Day begrudging return to school
would soon follow as much as it clearly
brought down his mood nothing lifted his
spirits like still getting to be out in
the snow and after a long day of helping
his mom take down the tinsel and pack up
the lights while his dad disposed of the
tree Michael was itching to go outside
please Mom he begged as a box of
decorations was placed back in the attic
his hands clasped together in a pleading
gesture please please please just 5
minutes I I won't go further than the
front yard Michaela sighed partly from
exhaustion but a smile crept on to her
face it was hard not to find her son's
love for the snow endearing all right
but only for 5 minutes she insisted
firmly and I want to see gloves hat and
a scarf not just a coat Mister with the
speed and excitement that she and her
husband had long since lost she watched
Michael race off to gather his warmest
winter coat remember when we were like
that Robert heed a sigh as he appeared
from chopping up that dried out
dehydrated remains of the Christmas tree
no do you Michaela replied with a light
chuckle before long Michael had dawned
his gloves and coat almost a size too
big his scarf was almost wrapping up his
entire head save for the little Bobble
hat that poked out at the top Robert
opened up the front door and his son
stepped out into a world that had been
whitewashed with clear cold snow given
that the Anderson lived on a small
Street in Grain Valley there weren't
many other people around especially not
with another flurry of snowfall moving
closer in the clouds up above but it
wasn't the next snowfall that the
residents of Grain Valley Missouri
should have been worrying about it was
the previous one the one that had
already fallen and what was now hiding
among the snow in the Anderson family's
front yard having few other kids his own
age to play with and not being allowed
to venture too far from the front porch
Michael was content to spend his
precious time Outdoors making snow
angels or practicing throwing snowballs
he had long been trying to get one to
clear the roof of the small house he and
his parents shared leaving a few
scattered patches of snow embedded on
the roof shingles a few meters from the
front door stood a snowman granted that
was hardly a rare sight at this time of
year especially in the cold weather but
what was so unusual about it was that
Michael hadn't remembered making a
snowman recently his parents hadn't let
him out in the snow on his own since the
start of the New Year given how badly
the downfall and icy winds had been for
the first week of January sure somebody
else could have made it taking a pause
as they passed by the Anderson's front
yard although not Michael Nor either of
his parents had spotted anyone doing
that the Snowman itself was featureless
the white of its ice cold body smeared
with mud and Dead Leaves debris that had
been packed in with the snow used in its
crude construction it was featureless
too whoever had made it hadn't gone to
the effort of giving it a face nor
draped an old scarf over or given it a
hat it just stood there but not like any
other snowman there was nothing
welcoming about it in fact it was
fittingly cold given how far away it
stood it was almost as if it was
watching the house curiously Michael
began to approach the Snowman being only
9 years old his imagination was
immediately running with the possibility
that this snow and mulch construct could
be alive much akin to the likes of
Frosty the Snowman little did did young
Michael Anderson know that he wasn't far
away from the truth although this
particular snowman wasn't quite the
happy Jolly soul from the much covered
holiday song he hadn't got that much
closer to the Snowman when he heard
something move nearer to where he stood
there was the rustle of leaves and the
Snapping of small Twigs coming up from a
bush next to him Michael couldn't see
what it was but it was far too low to
the ground and too close to the house
for it to be a bird maybe a possum or
raccoon had Gotten Trapped in the thin
branches and was now scrambling to try
and free itself diverting from
approaching the Snowman he walked closer
to the plant as he did the rustling got
louder more frantic almost hungry there
wasn't just one creature lurking out of
sight beneath the leaves but lots of
something Robert and Michaela had been
sitting indoors watching the TV when
they heard a spine chilling scream
coming from outside instantly they were
both up on their feet racing toward the
front door Robert threw it open and
Michael dashed inside in floods of
fearful tears what happened sweetie
Michaela asked concerned brushing
snowflakes from her son's coat are you
okay did you slip through crying and
sniffling shaking uncontrollably with
how afraid he was Michael couldn't find
the words to answer instead he pointed
through the still open door directly at
the Snowman still standing at the edge
of the front yard how long has that been
there Robert wondered aloud taking a
single step outside don't dad Michael
screamed but it was already too late
something small and Speedy had leaped
out of the snow in the front yard and
latched onto Robert's leg he howled as
he felt searing pain bitten by rows of
tiny pointed teeth as sharp as needles
and as bitterly cold as ice stumbling
back Robert Anderson fell over and
landed on the floor in the front hallway
inadvertently carrying whatever had
attacked him into his home both Michaela
and Michael screamed in fear as the tiny
creature clawed its way up Robert's leg
while he swatted at it frantically
trying to brush it away before it could
get Clos her with a blind swipe of his
hand he knocked the creature to the
floor and clambered to his feet arms
outstretched keeping his wife and son
behind him while staring into this
belief at what had bitten him it was
barely more than half a meter tall a
tiny white snowman bulbous bloodied eyes
bulge from its head much like those of
an insect directly between the eyes was
a hole a mouth not unlike a lampri lined
with rows of sharp teeth that all
pointed inwards it weared up and lunged
toward the Anderson family in a display
of aggression that caused all three of
them to jump weily backing away from the
snow creature it was then that Robert
and Michaela noticed what had frightened
their son so much out of the corner of
their eye they both simultaneously
caught the sight of the open front door
and the yard Beyond wiggling through the
snow shifting as they moved were even
more of the creatures slithering towards
the house like piranhas catching the
scent of blood in the water and standing
ominously just beyond the driveway was
the Snowman as if it was the General
commanding its troops to storm the house
the Andersons raced upstairs as a swarm
of snow creatures came spilling into the
house crawling from the yard onto the
floor and piling on top of each other
like ants to climb the stairs naturally
Michaela's first instinct as well as
protecting her son was to call the
police while Robert Held the door to the
bedroom shut Michaela held Michael close
and pleaded with the local grain Valley
Police Department to come and help them
although they only seemed to take the
call seriously when Michael started
screaming again one of the snow
creatures had pushed its way under the
door frame and was sneaking its way
towards Robert to attack him leaving a
trail of water behind it stepping back
and Thinking Fast Robert grabbed a
hairdryer and switched it on full blast
the Sudden Rush of electrically heated
air caused the toothy snow creature to
retreat into a corner refusing to let up
Robert got closer and kept the haird
dryer trained on it eventually causing
the creature to melt until little more
was left than a damp puddle but the
victory was momentary there were still
more of them crawling up the stairs
after the Andersons with their sharp
teeth they were gnawing at the wood of
the bedroom door trying to force their
way inside fortunately for Robert
Michaela and their son Michael they
wouldn't be able to recall the horrific
events of January 12th 2019 for much
longer by the time the local police
arrived it had become clear to the
officers responding that they were well
out of their depth especially when one
of them was injured suffering a bite
from a snow creature that was what led
the SCP Foundation being called in and
within 15 minutes they had dispatched
mobile task force operatives to secure
the anomaly being some of the
foundation's most highly trained agents
it didn't take long for the MTF to
neutralize the carnivorous snow
creatures however they quickly realized
that the mysterious snowmen that had
seemingly spawned the Swarm could not be
melted by any conventional means nor
would it deteriorate naturally on its
own a cover story was issued that
Michael had suffered an accident and
fallen down an open pothole that had
become obscured by heavy snowfall as a
result police officers were dispatched
to help him although the injury
sustained by one officer due to a bite
from a snow creature was never explained
following this the Anderson family was
administered amnestics meaning they
quickly forgot about the whole
terrifying ordeal maybe it was for the
best however young Michael seemed
irreparably changed he never went out to
enjoy the snow again repeatedly
suffering from nightmares about the cold
meanwhile the anomalous snowman was
recovered and thus designated as SCP
4230 immediately the SCP Foundation did
as their organization does best and
commenced testing with a human subject
no less they quickly discovered that SCP
4230 seemed to generate a sort of field
around itself that could trigger a
distinctive physiological change in any
human being or animal that came within 6
M of the Snowman this process became
known under the designation of SCP
42301 it appeared that Michael Anderson
had managed to unknowingly escape this
fate purely by not getting too close to
SCP 4230 staying just far enough away so
as not to trigger as CP
42301 the foundation placed D1
19375 a member of their d-class
personnel within this 6 M radius of the
Snowman and observed the gradual changes
he underwent over the following week for
Simplicity sake we'll refer to D1 19375
as frost a rather fitting moniker and
you'll soon see why within a day of
exposure to the Snowman Frost complained
to a senior researcher that he felt a
lot colder than usual although he
exhibited no other observable symptoms
beyond the coughing and sniffling of a
common cold by the following day Frost
was far worse for wear appearing to have
lost significant body mass to the point
where he had appeared to have been
malnourished his cold-like symptoms had
continued accompanied by disorienting
dizziness and as if if all that wasn't
bad enough his skin tone had seemingly
lost its natural pigment reduced to an
unnaturally pale shade as white as snow
day three saw Frost's body continued to
change rapidly at an alarming rate he
was internally producing an unknown
chemical that looked to be responsible
for enacting certain alterations namely
the dissolving of his femur and fibula
the cold and dizziness were also now
made all the worse by the addition of
pain to the man's lower body Frost even
reported to Foundation researchers
studying him that every movement he was
able to make caused him to suffer
extreme levels of physical pain but yet
rather than attempt to cure his
condition the foundation apathetically
observed noting down the process of SCP
42301 within 5 days of exposure to SCP
4230 naturally occurring substances
within Frost's body had traveled
downwards and solidified this was
followed by the most shocking stage of
the SCP 42301 process so far are and one
that made the foundation realize that
these weren't just changes it was a
transformation when day five saw Frost
skeleton physically reshaping itself his
head becoming a sphere and his arms
extending outwards like brittle Twigs it
soon became clear what was happening to
him he was turning into a snowman
rendered immobile and blind a week after
SCP 42301 began to take effect Frost had
started to secrete an unknown substance
this liid lowered his body temperature
freezing almost instantly and turning
his skin into an icy white Mass
worryingly similar to snow sure enough
on the Eighth Day the extent of the SCP
42301 process was made evident Frost had
already perished his body now looking
identical to a plain featureless Snowman
no eyes or face just a blank cold slate
but underneath the outer layer of snow
Frost's bones and the rest of his organs
were still contained inside from the
outside though he wasn't even human
anymore just an instance of what became
known as SCP 4230 a however being turned
into another Snowman by close proximity
to SCP 4230 wasn't even the worst part
by now you might be wondering what were
those snow creatures that attacked the
Andersons you'd be forgiven for thinking
that perhaps these were rodents or other
wild animals affected by SCP
42301 after all testing a shown that the
process doesn't just alter human
physiology but these carnivorous
needletooth creatures are known as SCP
4230 DBS and they are nasty little
critters to say the least when a person
or animal is turned into a snowman
during SCP
42301 becoming one of these instances is
far from the full extent of the
transformation the test the foundation
conducted on Frost and presumably on
numerous other d-class personnel as well
led to them discovering the further
alterations made when someone becomes an
SCP 4230 instance their freezing snow
and case bodies become hosts for white
spherical eggs after a subject like
frost becomes an SCP 4230 snowman these
eggs will hatch within 72 hours
producing up to 19 instances of SCP 4230
DB creatures the foundation was quick to
examine these bizarre snow spawn
Gathering up as many as they could for
testing they found that instances of SCP
4230 DB matured to adulthood remarkably
quickly reaching adulthood in 15 seconds
destroying the eggs containing these
creatures seemed to be an effective way
of preventing swarms of SCP 4230 DBS
from getting loose although the Snowman
each egg came from would also have to be
destroyed to achieve this result also
the lifespans of the smaller snow
creatures only lasted for a total of 24
hours and they would melt away after a
full day of life regardless of the
surrounding temperature SCP 4230 DB seem
uninterested in food that was presented
to them specifically one test involved
giving a snow creature a head of lettuce
and a watermelon the creature regarded
the fruit and vegetables with little
interest even refusing to eat either
despite prompts from the researchers
this painted the SCP 4230 dbes as
exclusive carnivores which explained why
they attacked the Anderson family they
were trying to eat them hunting the
Andersons at as a pack further testing
into SCP 4230 DBS revealed they had a
weakness to heat above a temperature of
40° F during another test a d-class was
sent into a cell with 10 of the
carnivorous snow creatures armed only
with a simple lighter an emergency flare
and 1 gallon of gasoline immediately all
10 of the SCP 4230 DBS crawled toward
the man hungry and determined him to be
a new source of food that is until they
noticed the lighter he was carrying the
d-class frantically clicked the spark
wheel until the flame danced from the
lighter causing seven of the creatures
to back away from the heat Source
cautiously the d-class was able to kill
the remaining three instances in
self-defense causing them to melt with
little effort he was Far luckier than
the subject of the next test would be
another declass was placed in a holding
cell with three of the snow creatures
and much like before they instantly
acknowledged his presence and began
approaching him however the foundation
had sent this member of d-class in
completely un armed without even so much
as a match to defend himself the
carnivorous beasts made short work of
their helpless victim feeding on what
was left the foundation was able to
dispatch instances of SCP 4230 DB with
relative ease even without waiting for
them to Simply melt after a day the use
of flamethrowers or drawing them into
warmer areas seemed effective enough at
destroying the small snowmen that
hatched out of SCP 4230 bodies however
some bright spark at the foundation
decided to test what would happen if the
opposite element was used against SCP
4230 DB creatures were they vulnerable
to the snow despite being made from a
snow- likee substance themselves another
test was conducted to answer this which
involved a small snowball being thrown
at one of the SCP 4230 DBS the result of
that incident has been entirely expunged
from the foundation's archives but it's
a safe guest to ask why evidently when
attacked using snow or ice SCP 4230 bees
are seemingly able to adapt in some way
that is determined to their attacker do
they add snow to their mass or become
even more aggressive it's hard to say
given the redactions but the result of
that final test were deemed so
catastrophic that the foundation banned
any further testing that involved SCP
4230 DBS as for where SCP 4230 first
came from the foundation is still
baffled the first reported incident
involving the Killer Snowman and the
carnivorous creature It produced came
when the Andersons found themselves
Under Siege by hungry SCP 4230 DBS maybe
the Snowman is just a freak of nature or
the result of an unknown pathogen or
microorganism carried in a snowstorm one
fateful night or perhaps SCP 4230 is
something far far more vicious whatever
the case we would recommend waiting for
the sun to come back out and the snow to
melt just to be safe Nothing in life can
prepare you for the raw heat of a house
on fire throwing an arm up in front of
his eyes and clasping a handkerchief to
his mouth Robert Chadford hacked up half
of the contents of his lungs glancing at
the material he saw that his Flem was
black poisoned by the smoke a beam
collapsed in front of him sending a
fresh wave of burning air into his face
so hot that it felt like it was going to
Scorch his ears off he had to run he had
to get out of the house but he knew he
couldn't his mother was upstairs
Robert barreled his way through the
Flames shouldering open doors and
stumbling along hallways the air was so
thick with smoke that he could barely
breathe so he collapsed to the floor and
started to crawl on his stomach he
reached the first step of the grand
staircase and started to heave himself
up one at a time feeling the heat of the
house threatening to engulf him more
with every inch he climbed but he hadn't
made it more than five steps before
there was an enormous creaking sound and
the whole staircase collapsed beneath
him Sparks rushed up into the air and
swirled around the room Flames licked at
the walls all around him as Robert
looked around at the collapsed staircase
he knew that it was hopeless with tears
streaming down his cheeks he pushed
himself forward and ran out of the house
the firemen swarmed past him filling the
building and shouting to one another but
Robert just stood there staring up at
the top floor window on the other side
of the glass surrounded by billowing
smoke he looked up at his mother sitting
as she always did on her rocking chair
utterly motionless as the house burned
around her in an undisclosed facility in
the United States of America you will
find what may well be the lowest
security containment cell in the entire
SCP Foundation there was no heavily
armored door no bulletproof glass no
machine guns about to drop down from the
ceiling at any point in fact there's
very little in the way of containment at
all
they often leave the door to the cell
wide open there is a window but on the
other side of it isn't a crowd of
researchers security guards and agents
ready to spring into action at a
moment's notice it's just a normal
double glazed window that looks out
across a Vista of fields trees and a
couple of power lines facing the window
is an old armchair in which the concrete
man sits SCP
014 he spends all of his day day every
day staring out of the window this view
specifically was chosen because very
little changes in it night turns today
the trees change with the seasons and it
rains occasionally but there are no
roads no new buildings springing up
nothing to distinguish it from how it
looked in
1937 beside him is a small table home to
a record player in the corner of the
room there's an antique set of shelves
that house three dozen old records all
dated from the 1930s or earlier all day
every day the music plays out of the old
speaker every so often as researchers
walk up and down the corridor if they
hear that there isn't any music playing
they'll come into the room and change
the record over for a new one the newest
researchers check in with SCP 014 to see
if he's okay he rarely responds and so
before long they stop asking you would
think therefore that the concrete man is
elderly approaching the Twilight years
of his life but the man who sits there
in his chair staring out of the window
and listening to music from almost 100
years ago appears to be just 30 years
old friends of Robert Chadford reported
a noticeable change in his demeanor
following the fire and death of his
mother he had lost his father not long
before to a workplace accident William
Chadford had been a construction worker
climbing up the girders of New York's
emerging Skyline pouring concrete and
piling bricks he had been working on a
new building one that was said to be the
tallest in the world called the Empire
State Building day after day he would
climb the cranes Teeter precariously
over the dizzying drops any slight
mistake and he would plummet hundreds of
feet often to the busy streets below
sure enough one day William chetford
worst fears came to life he was walking
on a gang plank that wobbled and bent
with every step he took on his shoulders
was a metal bar with a bucket of
concrete dang angled precariously from
each tip he walked this route every day
but clearly that day proved too much for
the wood to take the board splintered
and split beneath him plunging him down
and down through the scaffolding William
desperately reached out an arm and
managed to grasp the edge of a girder he
hung there helplessly staring up at his
colleagues high above him he cried out
for help and upon seeing him they began
to scramble down level by level to try
and rescue him he just needed to hang on
for a moment longer and they would
rescue him but one of them knocked over
a bucket of concrete William Chadford
could do nothing but watch as the heavy
sludge slowly tumbled towards his face
he tried to dodge it but it was no use
the company told Mrs chatford that this
had been William's Saving Grace that he
had been unconscious for the long fall
down to the streets below his fellow
workers knew that this wasn't the case
they heard his screams all the way down
Mrs Chadford didn't believe any of it
they were lying all of them the company
his co-workers everybody she knew what
had really killed him it was the same
thing that was killing her slowly the
same thing that had been passed on to
their son concrete poisoning she'd
approached the Wall Street Journal New
York Times and any Outlet she could but
none of them were remotely interested in
the story there were chemicals in the
concrete it wasn't safe to use it never
had been she'd been working in nursing
homes and seen the effects of concrete
on construction workers they'd become
paralyzed unable to move spending so
many years breathing concrete air
letting it absorb into their skin their
bodies had slowly started to turn into
it she knew it she started to go crazy
pinning up news clippings medical
journals photographs Maps anything she
could find all over her walls her entire
bedroom she had red string hanging from
the walls and ceiling connecting to
every surface Robert watched helplessly
from the doorway unable to do anything
anything as he saw his mother steadily
entering into psychosis but the further
her paranoia went the less energy she
seemed to have for it weeks went by and
her manic furor was replaced with
lethargy she got slower and slower in
her movements talked less and less at
meal times and began to sit down for
extended chunks of the day Robert
assuming that she was tired from grief
did what he could to help he carried an
armchair up to her room and placed it in
the corner by the window so so that she
could look out over the world around her
he thought she was resting but it soon
became apparent that she wasn't really
resting she was withdrawing almost
freezing over desperate to try and get
his mother to re-engage with the world
Robert sat down with her to try and
understand all of her conspiracy
theories around his father's death she
explained slowly and calmly that the
concrete being used in New York was
poisoned cursed she didn't know where it
had been dug up from how it had been
mixed or who was behind it but she was
getting close maybe it was the US
government maybe it was the same witches
maybe it was God himself but she knew
her husband and she knew he wouldn't
have fallen that day it walked across
that plank thousands of times without
incident there was no way he would have
made that mistake Robert tried to
connect the dots of what she was saying
did she really think that it was the
concrete that had killed his father she
said that it was in that the same
concrete is now killing her she showed
him her hands turned them over front and
back under the light for him to inspect
they looked just like normal hands
elderly wrinkled with deep veins popping
out but normal she scratched at them and
tried to faint pain for the effects of
her fingers look she said you see that
powder coming off them that's concrete
powder but Robert didn't see any of it
the concrete man came to the
foundation's attention a couple decades
ago con construction workers in New York
in the late 1990s were hard at work
clearing out the foundations for a new
skyscraper the site was built on top of
what used to be a residential block the
one Intrepid Builder soon discovered
Something That Shook him to his core
there was an old Cellar beneath where
the building used to be the lock on it
was Heavy thick with rust and had been
open for close to 70 years he and his
team managed to pry it open put on their
flashlights and went inside what they
found was a basement apartment still
sitting there beneath the rubble it was
a relic of its time thick dust covered
every surface ugly wallpapers surrounded
them and ancient appliances covered with
rust sat in the kitchen it was almost
like walking through a haunted house the
builders joked about ghosts stalking
these corridors as they made their way
through until they reached the bedroom
sliding the door open they faced a man
sitting there staring at them from an
old armchair the four Burly Builders
screamed like little girls for a split
second then and burst out laughing when
they realized that the man wasn't real
he must have been a wax work or
something he was sitting so perfectly
still and hadn't reacted at all to their
presence they went over to inspect what
he was made out of they tapped on his
forehead lifted his arms and dropped
them and were surprised at how
convincing the fake man was that was of
course until he politely asked them not
to touch him this time they really did
scream like girls running straight out
of the basement into a local police
station this basement apartment was
where Robert Chadford moved following
the fire in his parents' home and the
death of his paralyzed mother racked
with guilt he had never been quite able
to process what had happened to cause
his mother's mental state to deteriorate
so rapidly by the time she died she had
been looking at her hands and genuinely
believed they were made of concrete she
would not move she would not eat she
would not sleep for days she would just
sit staring out of her window he knew he
should have taken her to a doctor but
they just couldn't afford it maybe if he
had this would have all worked out
differently Robert would think about it
hour after hour he would sit down in the
armchair in the corner of his room and
Ponder what had happened it was
difficult to keep track of time living
in the basement there were no windows no
daylight at all but he didn't think he
had been sitting there for very long
when he noticed the skin on his hands
starting to turn gray without Panic he
slowly lifted his hands to his eyes and
inspected what was happening his finger
down to about halfway through his palms
were dry and solid he could move them
just about but it took a normal effort
and he could see cracks running along
the back of the concrete when he did so
he decided not to he wouldn't say he
felt calm exactly maybe disconnected he
didn't feel particularly hungry he
didn't feel particularly tired in fact
he didn't feel much at all his concrete
limbs were only a passing curiosity to
him as he sat in his chair very
occasionally he would get up to put on a
record on his record player then return
to his seat and stare at the wall that
would be every couple of months at most
the rest of the time he would just sit
there one day he noticed in a vague
corner of his mind that the ground was
shaking and dust was filling the room
The Ripping sound of dynamite and the
heavy Stone just above his head told him
that the apartment block towering over
him had fallen down and almost come
through his ceiling Robert just sat
there unconcerned another day some
indeterminate time later a group of
Builders came in dressed in Peculiar
futuristic clothing with bright yellow
hats and reflective vests they seemed
rather startled to see him though in
truth he had little care for seeing them
what did perturb him was when a group of
people claiming to be Agents from the
foundation came into his room and
carried him out he didn't like the noise
didn't like the change if he wanted to
move he would move not that he could of
course he was now entirely made made of
concrete but that was beside the point
these people put him in the back of a
van and drove him across half of the
United States they wielded him through
brightly lit rooms and into a disgusting
modern white box they had done the
courtesy of bringing his chair along and
found a new record player for him with a
whole selection of albums lining a shelf
on the wall he would have appreciated it
and said thank you to them but he didn't
really care he wasn't present at all
this was of course due to the fact that
he was made of concrete by this point
however once he was sat in his chair and
took in the sight in front of him Robert
Chadford felt a dull Panic rising in his
chest they placed him at a window just
like he' placed his dying mother in
front of a window he tried to clench his
jaw tried to move his hands tried to cry
out in fear and pain but he couldn't he
was paralyzed the smell of smoke filled
his chest choking him torturing him as
the memories of his burning household
raged in his mind he tried to scream he
tried to fight he tried to do anything
other than just sit there but it was far
too late for any of that good afternoon
Mr chatford the researcher said busying
herself and putting on another album for
him to listen to is there anything I can
do for you sir anything I can do to make
you more comfortable the concrete man
said nothing the researcher patted him
on the back of his hand made of concrete
indeed looks just like regular skinned
to me Mr chatford I do wonder what's
going on inside that head of yours on
her way out of the room glanced at his
view from the window beautiful weather
outside today isn't it scorching even
the creature let out an unmistakable
squeal of Rage as stimulus y 835 took
effect Dr Christensen pressed his face
up against the glass eager to see the
results it had to work this time it
simply had to he was certain that this
attempt would make all the other
failures worth it and he'd once again
Pro the foundation's faith in him to be
well placed SCP 56 83 shrieked a loud
insect-like sound that would have
normally made the blood run cold of
anyone that heard it but to Dr
Christensen it was like music a
monster's dying Fanfare to mark his
success soon he'd be the researcher who
neutralized not one but two tenacious
highly adaptable anomalies the senior
researcher could feel his heart racing
as the deadly giant spider started to
Twitch then burst into two identical
entities
the pair of arachnid anomalies had
reacted much like the results of the
tissue sample tests conducted earlier
dividing into two separate organisms
Christensen held his breath the tissue
samples had destroyed each other
attacking and injecting the other with
lethal doses of Venom surely he reasoned
duplicating SCP 5683 into two would have
the same result his heart sank as he
watched one of the spider creatures the
duplicate perish almost immediately as
it often did when presented with human
prey SCP 5683 attacked using its
mandibles and impaled its copy with its
front legs to pin it in place the Clone
had bitten back with Dr Christensen
already knowing that would have granted
SCP 5683 an immunity to its own Venom
its powers of adaptation were fiercely
frustratingly efficient and nothing
demonstrated this more than the intense
reaction from the man tasked with
destroying it Dr Christensen hurled the
nearest object a coffee mug at a glass
window of the observation room
overlooking the test chamber he pounded
his fist against the glass hardly with
the required Force to cause damage but
enough to send pain shooting down
christensen's wrist which then nestled
in his forearm a reminder that the
experiment like the others had failed
why can't I destroy you he muttered
through clenched teeth looking with with
hatred at the enormous spider in the
chamber below the directive had reached
him the day immediately after New Year's
Day 2020 and straight from a member of
the 05 Council no less their message
expressed how impressed the council was
with Dr christenson's success with the
Doomsday Clock project and how favorably
his name had been mentioned in Council
meetings this voted well for the
ambitious Foundation doctor he'd been
hoping to snag the director position at
site 04 now that director Bray had
retired but there was one more test from
the 05 Council they wanted Dr
Christensen to use the knowledge
garnered during his previous success to
solve the SCP 5683 problem if he could
successfully complete that assignment it
would be his ticket to being promoted
with the comfy role of site director and
all its perks in mind Dr Christensen
accepted the assignment from the council
to deal with SCP 5683 3 SCP 5683 was
quite the Beast not an anomaly for those
with intense Arachnophobia the huge
spider-like organism was extremely
hostile towards humans and had to be
kept in a constant state of medical
sedation otherwise it would relentlessly
attempt to breach containment and
Slaughter any and all Personnel in its
path what had made SCP 5683 such a
problem for the foundation was the
creature's ability to rapidly regenerate
damage as well as modify its own body in
reaction to threats much like a certain
particularly hardto destroy reptile The
spider-like Entity could adapt itself to
become more resistant to any danger
posed to it and of course this meant
that the foundation needed this
dangerous creature eradicated the
frequent containment breaches and sheer
number of casualties caused by the
arachnid anomaly were significant enough
to cause an increasing drain on the SCP
foundation's resources so with a
termination order coming from the very
top the 05 Council themselves Dr
Christensen was tasked with overseeing
the neutralization of SCP
5683 during an initial deliberation Dr
Christensen met with researcher miles
and Hall Junior researchers Silva and
security Chief ad to discuss earlier
attempts to terminate SCP
5683 the new head of the termination
project was perturbed to learn that the
research team had little in the way of
useful information to offer
beyond what the foundation already knew
about the creature but Christensen
decided some basic stress testing would
at least be a start after a successful
tissue sample test where in some of SCP
5683 genetic material was incinerated Dr
Christensen tried to Simply destroy the
spider with fire an understandable
response to say the least however
exposing SCP 5683 to temperatures of
850° C for just 30 seconds didn't quite
yield the easy Victory he had hoped for
the arachnid thrashed about and
screeched in reaction to the heat only
to rapidly develop a form of armor
plating covering its entire body the
armor was comprised of an unknown
unidentifiable substance but it was
enough to prevent SCP 5683 from
combusting reconvening with the rest of
the team Dr Christensen hid his pride
assuring everyone he was just trying to
establish a baseline during the previous
test of course he hadn't believed that
terminating SCP 5683 with fire would be
a success or so he claimed hiding how
much he longed for an easy solution so
he could snatch up the vacant sight 04
director position but to ensure the
others Christensen explained that he'd
requisition some anomalous materials
from the 05 Council that they'd be using
in their next termination attempts
nothing that was anomalous enough to
require containment but toxic enough
that they presented a few options for
destroying SCP p
5683 uh just for logging purposes sir
may I inquire about the specific
substances we're shipping in junior
researcher Sylvia had asked of course y
220 y 835 and y43 Dr Christensen quickly
recounted them all from memory I'm told
they should be arriving within the week
I expect each would be enough to do the
job but it's best to hedge our bets this
spider doesn't compared to the lizard
I'll tell you that Junior researchers
Silva seemed to take an interest in what
Dr Christian had just alluded to his
previous work with the lizard he probed
further about it and Christensen gave a
solemn response the aspiring Foundation
doctor recalled an incident from a few
years earlier during his experimentation
with SCP 682 some of the methods Dr
Christensen had opted to employ in an
attempt to destroy the hard to destroy
reptile had led to a severe Containment
Breach when describing it he used the
word unpleasant perhaps out of guilt at
how many personnel had lost their lives
due due to his actions brushing the
topic aside he assured the team to get
on with testing the new anomalous
stimuli on SCP
5683 stimulus y220 initially showed some
promise during a tissue sample test it
successfully converted part of SCP 5683
into glass which then violently exploded
leaving nothing behind but attempts to
use it to neutralize the creature itself
quickly quash those promising results
within 9 seconds of being exposed to
stimul y220 SCP 5683 is body rapidly
turned to glass around 80% of its
arachnid Mass proceeded to explode
shattering in all directions sending
clear shards showering over the testing
chamber as he watched Dr christens send
allowed himself to believe that this was
mission accomplished that he'd
successfully terminated as CP
5683 but his celebration was premature
the spider quickly began reconstituting
itself its body regenerating within the
space of 30 seconds after testing with
both stimuli y220 and Y 8355 Dr
christensen's frustration seemed to be
increasing with each failed attempt he
knew his promotion was Within Reach and
as far as he could remember he done good
work with damaging SCP 682 why should
eradicating this anomalous spider be any
different however it was a test with
stimulus y 436 that enraged the
ambitious doctor expecting the anomalous
stimulant to turn as PP 5683 into a fine
Mist Christensen watched as the
creature's body vanished literally
vaporizing changing states of matter to
little more than water in the air
suddenly every light in the facility
powered off plunging the testing chamber
into darkness when the lights came back
on SCP 5683 was standing on all eight
legs right where it had been missed only
3 seconds earlier the research team had
gathered for another mediation and Dr
christensen's anger still hadn't
subsided he kicked a chair to emphasize
his frustration alarming Junior
researcher Silva who urged him to calm
down after eventually cooling his temper
Christensen made an announcement that
caused even greater concern to spread
amongst the team I'm requisitioning y910
researcher halls and researcher miles
objected trying to get Dr Christensen to
realize that the course of this action
was excessive Overkill even but
Christensen disregarded them standing by
his latest method for terminating as SCP
5683 the global occult Coalition had
previously used y910 to poison Gods he
felt sure that it would work on one
anomalous giant spider his time was
running short Dr Christensen was aware
that any day now the 05 Council would be
appointing a replacement director of
site 04 and he wanted that promotion and
he didn't seem to care what Corners he
cut and what risks he took to get there
even if it meant endangering his
research search Personnel Dr Christensen
declared that in order to save time he
would be bypassing tissue samples to
test for termination attempts the longer
it took to terminate the anomalous
arachnid the more his window of
opportunity closed and the further the
director position slipped from his
fingertips accepting full responsibility
for The Reckless decision and anything
that might go wrong Dr Christensen
wanted to use stimulus y910 directly on
SCP
5683 he urged the research team to make
the necessary preparations unaware of
what his decision would lead to and the
chaos it had already caused the test was
catastrophic so much so that it caused a
Containment Breach with SCP 5683 loose
and scuttling about the facility on its
multiple legs Dr Christensen and Junior
researchers Silva were forced to rush to
the secure bunker on site for safety
Christensen was in a state of panic
until he noticed something and not for
the first time either he he'd been
detecting a foul smell whenever he'
conducted the meetings to discuss
termination options but the other
members of the research team had quickly
explained it was nothing more than
repeated accidents in the cafeteria but
here was the stench again worse than
ever yet Junior researcher Silva brushed
it off again stating that SCP 5683 must
have gotten into the facility's reactor
the junior researcher quickly became
inconsolable stating that the whole
situation was his fault Dr Christensen
interjected demanding to know how it was
and what Silva had done to cause the
situation he replied that it was his
duty to oppose ill-advised actions and
when Christensen had declared his
intention to use y910 the Junior
researcher hadn't opposed him Shifting
the blame from himself onto his
subordinate Dr Christensen chastised
Silva over how many personnel had died
because of the junior researchers
refusal to do his job ignoring that it
was christensen's own Ambitions that had
led to the current chaos refusing to be
made a scapegoat Dr Christensen vowed to
pin the full culpability for SCP 5683
Containment Breach onto Junior
researcher Silva saying he tell the 05
Council the so-called truth about what
had happened but Silva pointed out that
there wasn't much of a likelihood that
the bunker would survive the reactor
overloading he urged the ambitious
Foundation doctor to admit some
responsibility of his own for what had
happened but Christensen refused
suddenly there came a thunderous banging
at the bunker door a debilitating Pang
of fear struck Dr Christensen causing
him to scream and Retreat from the
entrance yelling no and please as if he
was pleading with the universe itself to
spare him from the spider Junior
researcher Silva walked over to the
bunker door just as strong arachnid legs
tore the heavy steel bulkhead off its
hinges like it was made of little more
than wet paper there was SCP
5683 the enormous spider gettering Into
the Bunker screeching all the while
Silva had put himself between SCP 5683
and the ambitious Foundation doctor
whose hunger for a promotion had led to
all this Carnage the junior researcher
announced his Noble intention to
sacrifice himself occupying the creature
while urging Christensen to run the
doctor shoved Silva towards the spider
and prepared to run then all of a sudden
SCP 5683 vanished Junior researcher
Silva told Dr Christensen he was
disappoint pointed before researcher
miles researcher Hall and security Chief
ad all entered the bunker through the
torn open hole where the door had been
Christensen questioned where SCP 5683
had gone to which Silva explained there
was little reason to keep a dummy around
once it had served its purpose as a
substitute you mentioned you worked with
a lizard sir the junior researcher
recounted that there was a Containment
Breach if you don't terribly mind me
asking how did you you escape that
situation it seemed quite lethal didn't
it afraid and Confused Dr Christensen
asked where he was Hall and Miles urged
him not to ask questions he already knew
the answer to Silva explained who they
all were a jury specifically Dr
christensen's jury and according to them
the ambitious doctor had disgraced
himself again Christensen had been there
for a long time a considerably long time
reliving the same events over and over
again with SCP 5683 acting as a
substitute for SCP 682 it was the same
situation he'd made the same decisions
the same mistakes and it had cost lives
now Dr Christensen was trapped in an
endless loop Penance for the casualties
that had occurred at his hands all in
the pursuit of his own selfish personal
gain he asked the jury how long he'd be
stuck there a question Sila responded to
with until you take responsibility sir
immediately Dr Christensen tried to
admit that this all had been his fault
but he didn't mean it not really he
hadn't accepted blame he just wanted a
quick and easy way out of the loop and
the jury of his deceased Personnel knew
it Christensen ran for the door in the
hopes of escaping his fate futile as his
chances were a black iron chain appeared
from around the corner and wrapped
itself around the over ambitious
doctor's throat ignorant of his pleas
for forgiveness saying he was sorry
wouldn't bring back the people who died
in service of his aspirations to
becoming a site director the chain
dragged Dr Christensen through the
facility at such a speed that he
collided with every wall and every
corner as he turned sharply being pulled
along the floor but that and the walls
quickly crumbled away revealing a sight
that made Dr Christensen start screaming
that it wasn't his fault fault and he
never really stopped What followed
involved a great deal of blood and fire
once it was over it left behind the same
awful stench the doctor had smell before
and he'd soon be smelling it again too
as the cycle repeated itself the
directive had come straight from a
member of the 05 Council they were
impressed with Dr Christensen and the
ambitious Foundation doctor had been
hoping to snag a director position at
site 04 but there was one final test for
Dr Christensen to solve the SCP
5683 problem it was late October of 1993
and John Matthews of Myrtle Beach South
Carolina had just scored a date with
Sarah one of the most popular girls in
school and he had planned the perfect
night out for the two of them a haunted
house had just been set up in town and
he like many guys before him figured he
could use that as a chance to impress
his date he' already been through the
attraction so he knew EX exactly when to
put his arm around Sarah when one of the
costume actors or animatronics tried to
spook them if any of them got too close
for comfort he might even punch them
just to show Sarah How brave he was that
would be a Surefire way to impress any
girl however Jon had no idea of the real
horror that waited for him and his day
through the doors of this seemingly
normal fun house at first the haunted
house went as normal Jon laughed at all
the fake cobwebs and plastic skeletons
making sure Sarah knew how dumb he
thought they looked he shoved away
actors dressed as axe murderers and told
them to stay away from his date it was
dark so they couldn't really see each
other's faces but Jon guessed that Sarah
was probably really impressed all in all
the date was going well until they got
to a room that Jon hadn't seen the first
time he'd been through it seemed like it
had been added overnight but at the same
time it didn't match with the theme the
theme of the haunted house this year
year was cannibal hotel but this room
looked more like Dracula's castle
complete with actors dressed as
Frankenstein The Wolf Man and Dracula
himself one of them was even a dead
ringer for the actor Vincent Price John
and Sarah watched confused as the actors
performed their routines which just like
their surroundings seemed out of place
it was total hacknet full of lame puns
and very basic scares though the special
effects were undeniably impressive when
Jon and Sarah walked through the room
the actor dressed as Dracula stood in
front of Jon and started pretending to
hypnotize him up close he did look a lot
like Bella legosi the actor who'
portrayed the count during his first big
screen appearance this definitely threw
JN off a little but unfortunately this
Dracula didn't have lugosi's acting
talents you are under my control Dracula
said waving his fingers at Jon and
staring at him Jon getting really sick
of this pushed the guy out of the way to
move on to the next room but when he did
he felt that something was really really
wrong here he practically dragged Sarah
away from watching The Wolf Man
transform and ran the rest of the way
through the house all of his bravado now
gone Sarah asked her date what was wrong
and he didn't tell her how could he
without sounding crazy when he had
touched that actor playing Dracula
something hadn't felt right even through
his suit and Cape John had been able to
tell that something was wrong he was
cold and rigid not like a human being
but like a robot or a wax dummy this is
just one of multiple complaints from
Halloween attractions around the United
States that prompted the action of the
SCP Foundation several witnesses
described either seeing people that
resembled classic movie Monsters or
living wax models of those monsters
appearing in various haunted houses corn
mazes carnivals and strip malls across
the country the foundation has
designated this troop of hammy wax
actors SCP
4153 during performances SCP 4153 use
wax to alter their appearance produce
props including fake blood and gore and
even manipulate wax objects from afar
while this results in some uncanny
special effects the content of the
performances tend to be pretty standard
classic haunted house Fair they mostly
do things like reenacting scenes from
classic horror films and telling spooky
jokes with a little fake blood here and
there when the foundation arrived
arrived at the Myrtle Beach attraction
they apprehended the various wax
characters and determined that their
Eerie resemblance to the classic horror
characters wasn't just makeup after the
horrors some of these Foundation
employees had seen on the job living wax
models of Frankenstein's monster and
Dracula seemed almost cute in comparison
and the troop of wax actors were taken
to site 9 for questioning and
containment the first member of the
troop to be interviewed on site was
Dracula dubs SCP 4153 017 by the
Foundation he was interviewed by agent
Timothy West who was totally unimpressed
with Dracula's shtick he tried to
hypnotize agent West an act which he
flatly refused to indulge in Dracula
provided the agent with seemingly no
useful information only responding to
questions with cliches like we were all
dead the whole time and the log was
coming from inside the house the next
wax figure to be interrogated was
Frankenstein's monster AKA SCP 4153
3-15 who was interviewed by agent
Samantha henwick much like how SCP 4153
d017 stayed fully in character as
Dracula during his interview SCP 4153
015 seemed to really believe that he was
actor Boris carof who played
Frankenstein's monster in the
1930s the SCP spoke in an exact
imitation of Carlo's voice and speech
patterns and talked to agent henwick as
if she was another actor on a movie set
he he talked about how honored he was to
be part of the project and asked are we
rolling when he noticed the conversation
was being recorded agent Henrik
responded to the scp's comments with
confusion a fact which he took to mean
that she was staying in character like a
true actor he took a moment to prepare
himself before pulling his own head off
much to the horror of agent henwick the
last and probably most interesting of
the interviews conducted in 1993 was
with the wax figure who resembled
Vincent Price more specifically
Vincent Price in his role as Henry Jared
in 1953's House of Wax a movie about a
mad sculptor who made wax figures out of
the corpses of his victims this wax
figure was designated SCP
415336 and was interviewed by agent
Gerald Penn Penn started the interview
with a simple question why do you try to
frighten people s SCP
415336 had an equally simple answer why
does anyone try to to frighten it's fun
to be frightened almost as much fun as
it is to do the
frightening pen was skeptical pointing
out that the wax figures act wasn't
especially frightening the SCP laughed
dismissively telling pen to have some
respect for the classics pen was still
not having any of it he had been with
the SCP Foundation for 20 years at this
point and he'd seen enough Real Horror
that the so-called Classics had no
effect on him whatsoever he pressured
price for answering
but instead of responding with a
straight answer price launched into a
speech about his feelings on
Monsters he said you'll call any o with
a steak knife hunting gaggles of teens a
monster these days there's no wit no
humor no charm where's the passion the
artisanship whereas the sense of theater
would you like to know something
peculiar I've almost never played a
monster or I've played villains most
certainly but not monsters only men
besieged by Fate driven to Revenge still
I've always had a fondness for them even
as a child I sympathize more with the
monster than the hero agent pen who at
this point was really getting tired of
all the theatrics started to interject
but when he opened his mouth to speak he
was only able to get a few words out
before his tongue went numb and rigid in
his mouth he could no longer move it
agent Penn tried to speak but his tongue
was too solid and heavy to do anything
more than knock uselessly against his
bottom teeth he felt something dislodge
inside his mouth and he hoped maybe it
was the feeling of his tongue being
freed from whatever spell the SCP had
put it under but then he started to feel
a tearing and a sticky heaviness in his
bottom jaw agent pen reached up and felt
around inside his mouth he started to
scream indistinctly when he realized to
his horror that his tongue had ripped
off he pulled it out of his mouth and
when he held it in his hand his fears
were confirmed somehow it had become
nothing more than a lump of pink wax now
completely tongueless agent pen
continued to babble frantically no doubt
trying to curse at the wax creature
sitting in front of him SCP
415336 finally paid attention to his
interviewer's distress at this point he
turned to agent Penn with a look of
disapproval and disappointment and said
oh dear your tongue seems to have gotten
away from you there here allow me the
SCP leaned towards agent pen and though
the agent wanted to resist he found that
he could no longer move his arms in fact
his whole body had gone numb and rigid
just like the wax tongue the only
movement he was capable of was opening
his mouth and the wax fa simile of
Vincent Price started molding his tongue
back to the proper shape and reattached
it inside agent Penn's mouth agent Penn
whimpered unable to do anything while
the scp's hands were in his mouth the
creature said hash now I warned you
about this I told you that you mustn't
disturb the wax before it hardens that
is a crucial part of the process it
needs to solidify otherwise you risk
disturbing the performance by the time
his tongue was reattached and reeal
agent Penn was on the verge of tears he
gurgled gasping for air wiggling his
tongue around in his mouth to make sure
that it worked the SCP returned to his
seat pleased with his own handiwork
Splendid Splendid good is new now let's
take it from the top shall we agent pen
took a deep breath steuding himself as
SCP
415336 whispered the word action pen
resumed the interview with the same
simple question why do you try to
frighten people SCP
415336 gave the same simple answer why
does anyone try to frighten it's fun to
be frightened almost as much fun as it
is to do the frightening the interview
continued for only a few minutes longer
with both parties repeating only things
they said earlier in the recording the
log ends with SCP
415336 once again saying have some
respect for the classics not long after
the interview concluded Foundation
management completely lost contact with
site 9 a mobile task force was sent in
to investigate the cause of this loss of
contact and on arrival they found a
catastrophic Containment Breach not a
single member of on-site Personnel was
found alive and strangely all of their
bodies seemed to be coated in wax
further examination revealed that this
initial observation wasn't the case at
all they weren't just coated in wax no
every member of the site 9 team had all
of their major organs including their
skin surgically extracted and replaced
with sculpted wax of course this was
assumed to be the doing of SCP 4153 but
oddly all of the autopsies suggested
that the removal of organs had happened
weeks before the apprehension of SCP
4153 even though all of the on-site
Personnel had seemed alive and well
right up until the Containment Breach
outside of being replaced by Wax no
damage was done to the bodies it seemed
that everyone had just dropped dead at
the same time there was one body that
was different though that of agent
Gerald Penn agent Penn's decapitated
body was found in the same containment
cell that had been used for SCP
415336 next to the body was a photograph
showing SCP
415336 holding up agent Penn's screaming
head and on the back a single sentence
was written from one horror fishion to
another always stay ahead all the SCP
4153 instances remain unaccounted for an
MTF Iota 10 also known as the damn feds
continue to monitor for new sightings
and reports of activity that may be
linked to the wax troop hopefully one
day they'll be taken into Foundation
custody and Ain and maybe all it will
take is for them to meet someone with a
sufficient appreciation for the classics
now for something from the more
terrifying archives of the SCP
Foundation check out scp096 the shy guy
or SCP 106 the old man